Hello everyone!
I'm live!
Hello everybody!
We are watching a concert, but before we begin, I want to
say a huge thank you to PUBG Blindspot for today's sponsor.
We are here for day two!
Oh wait, oh my god, I hear myself.
Give me a sec.
I hear myself.
Let me fix that real quick.
Anyway, we are watching a concert, a pre-recorded concert of
the music for, uh, that was just the echo was me.
Um, I had my own tab out.
So we are watching a pre-recorded concert of the music for
PUBG that was at the, that was being played at the studio.
Um, uh, so my, I told my teammates, I told them like, uh,
hey, it will be around 40 minutes so our first game starts,
uh, and then And they're like, all right, peace.
They're like, all right, we'll be back in 20 to 30 minutes.
Peace.
I was like, okay, that's cool.
No, no, I get it.
I get it, though.
That's why I'm alone.
That's why I'm alone in the PC right now.
They're like, bro, we're not starting.
We're not starting yet.
I was like, no, we just, you gotta wait a little bit.
Like, all right, peace.
Fades away.
yeah honestly fair no I honestly fair I didn't want them to
be like when's the first game I was like we still have we
saw some of the concert lavender I don't want them to be
like bro what the fuck you know so so I'm giving them a
little break time a little bit of a break me time you know
they get some me time before they they're here
I miss pretty sick music.
Also, is the music loud enough?
I don't know.
Bum-bum-bum.
Bum-bum.
Yeah, and then I told them.
I told them, like, guys, I would really love to make it to
the next round.
Because if I get knocked out, I will still have the B.
Don't keep coming back.
They left you to lose.
alone simple they even super chat no they said they'll come
back they literally were here like they were here like five
minutes i swear to god they were here five minutes ago i
said hi to them and i was like i gave them a warning being
like yeah our first game isn't gonna be until until like uh
until like maybe uh 40 minutes and they're like all right
i'm gonna i'm gonna go do other things now and i was like oh
okay bye
um so yeah i did tell them i was like hey guys i would
really appreciate it we make it today too because i really
don't want to do like the walk of shame um because i still
have to be live after we lose uh to like all the way till
the end of the tournament so it would be really cool if i
don't have the walk of shame of being knocked out and still
still live
The life of shame.
Gus, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's like you let your teammates go, Doki.
The accident wasn't your fault.
Actually, I think I was the one that got most friendly fired
out of everybody.
Other than Heavenly.
I felt our Gomes.
I feel like I was getting the most friendly fired.
But thank you for the super chat, Gus.
Thank you.
Fair enough.
But the drummer's going fucking hard right now.
If I'm not last, guys.
Not last.
That's for sure.
Wait, nobody else is in the team voice.
Like...
Why is it...
Why am I...
I'm like the only one in the PC.
Oh yeah, I should...
Oh wait, did I tweet?
I'm live?
Okay, I did it.
Live now.
Main...
broadcast on twitch uh my pov on youtube main broadcast on
twitch there you go post i forgot to tweet i was live bum
bum bum bum bum don't know bump bump bump bump leave the vc
it's okay i'll stay here I'll wait until they come back.
I need to know they'll come back, guys.
Bottom, bottom, bottom, bottom, bottom, bottom, bottom.
Bottom, bottom, bottom, bottom, bottom, bottom, bottom,
bottom, bottom, bottom, bottom, bottom, bottom, bottom,
bottom, bottom, bottom, bottom.
You got Twitch chat?
Oh, no.
The main broadcast is handled by the production company.
So, um.
So, it's just me.
It's just me on YouTube.
My POV is on YouTube and the main broadcast.
We're a team.
Our first match is to start until maybe an hour.
So, um, I gave them a little bit of, I gave them a lunch
break.
Because I'd feel bad, you know.
They're just waiting here.
I was like, you guys don't have to stick around until our
first match.
And they were like, bet, peace.
No hesitation.
They're like, all right, bye.
Hey, but guys, free rave.
Free rave.
I mean, I'd feel bad, though, you know, waiting, uh, waiting
for an hour.
So I just, you know, gave them a lunch break before then, a
little recess.
Yeah,
this is apparently a, like, performance after, at the
office.
Oh, yeah, for those who are curious, This is on the main
broadcast, which is on my Twitch channel.
But the reason why there's no archive, there's no VOD of it
is because this is from, you know, it is from Crafton, which
is like the GameStyle is located in Korea.
And because of that, Twitch has like this thing where if
they see any connection from Korea, they're not allowed to
store any broadcast.
from Korean IP so that's why there was no archive I was very
confused too yeah I was just like we're just like where
where did the VODs go and then we were like they're like did
you delete it I was like I'm pretty sure I didn't delete it
I didn't barely touch my twitch and I googled it and I was
like oh it's a twitch regulation thing yeah I was like I'm
sorry no I didn't delete it I I swear.
I was like, I swear to God.
Also,
I'm like debating if I stream, if I do a Lunar New Year
stream tomorrow or the day after tomorrow because like
tomorrow is lunar new year but like i really want to go to a
lunar new year festival because i haven't gone to one in a
very very long time i want to see the line dance live i've
been getting super nostalgic and stuff but they usually last
like all the way tonight too i have something planned for a
lunar new year it's something really fun um but it's like I
feel like...
Yeah, I really want to go to a Lunar New Year festival.
So I'm debating whether or not to do it tomorrow or the day
after tomorrow.
Because I need to check the dates, too, to see, like...
I know, like, there's one on the 17th.
But, like, I want to see if there's...
Because I know there's some festivals that are, like,
multi-day.
So I'm going to check it out.
If there's multi-day, then I'll do a Lunar New Year stream
tomorrow.
But if it isn't, if it's just tomorrow, then I'll just do it
um abyssal thank you the super chat thank you thank you yes
it is my twitch channel if you go to to my main broadcast
would be a jokie bird uh twitch.tv slash jokie bird that is
the main broadcast uh so uh so yeah that's where the main
like povs are but i don't want to i want to see the lions
eat a cabbage and then give me good luck because apparently
like the symbol for them eating cabbages is that they bring
you good luck and good fortune.
They're spinning like if they're like I remember when the
cabbages are like good luck and good fortune.
Festival then stream.
Yeah but then it'll be really late.
I don't like streaming too late for you guys.
Like by the time I come back from the festival it'd be like
super duper late and also I might be very tired I'm craving
I've been craving mingao mingo mingo.
I almost like like merged Cantonese and Mandarin together.
Oh my god.
I love mingo They're so good It's like it's like it's
basically like rice cakes
I missed those Especially when you do like scrambled eggs
and honestly I hope so you back This is like their own
personal concert after like lunch break.
I noticed that they're like eating lunch and there's like...
Yeah, you can see like PUBG in the background.
It's not over.
We haven't even gotten to the PUBG blind spot songs yet,
Mark.
Wait, this isn't a PUBG blind spot song?
What songs are they playing?
I feel like playing, Mark.
I feel like playing.
That's what I'm feeling like.
No, you can't play.
The lunch concert.
Yeah, wait.
Do I show up to the volume more, guys?
Or is it...
Show up to volume more chat?
This would get your team pumped.
Oh, yes.
Oh, it's from PUBG.
Yeah, I see the PUBG decorations in the back.
All right, I'll pay a little bit more for you guys.
Oh my god, the beat drop!
I'm waiting for the drop!
When's the drop?
Yeah, idiot.
You guys don't know.
Oh my god.
It's actually recorded inside the beat drop.
But Mark has actually been, and he keeps telling me, office
when the beat drop live performance to everyone that's
inside the office at this point in time which uh honestly is
uh all right is it better guys the volume it's perk but i'd
like to have as well
oh oh oh oh Oh!
The beat drop!
Hold!
Here it comes!
It's already here!
I'm so tired.
Build up.
Dragoon Raid at 3 p.m.
Let's go!
The earliest time for the rave.
I don't know.
But that drummer is having a time of his life right now.
No, this is pre-recorded.
It's not live.
Because then it would be like...
Really early for like...
Wait, what time would it be right now in Korea if this was
supposedly live?
I feel so bad for everyone.
Like, we gotta do this concert at...
Yeah, it would be like 8 a.m.
8 a.m.
concert for the people.
For the people in NA.
Yeah, yeah, it's a lot.
I need that energy right now.
6 a.m.
or 8 a.m.
breakfast rave.
Yeah, I was like, guys, maybe like 8 a.m.
might be too early for a rave, guys.
All right, that either says, Hope you enjoy the festivals
there, and coincidentally, it falls on my birthday.
Thank you for the magenta soup, guys, bro.
Thank you, thank you.
I can't read, but that's what I guess, what it means due to
context.
I hope I'm right.
But yeah, happy birthday.
Wow, what a coincidence.
Emily birthday is on the same day as Lunar New Year.
But happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Zoro.
Yeah, happy birthday.
Oonce, oonce, oonce, oonce, oonce.
Oonce, oonce, oonce, oonce.
Oh my god, we have your own personal concert, girl.
Your own personal concert for your birthday.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
he is it's like his like morning workout I love how this is
actually like a lunch concert for for the people working
there that's the life you get your you get your lunch and
then you're like oh my gosh my own personal concert at the
office go drummer go pause mark i'm i mean he's just giving
it all bump for real wait that's the song which is it that's
fine i can't recognize this anywhere we've been listening to
it on loop yesterday it's like ingrained in my head now i
was like i know that riff anywhere i We've been listening to
it for four hours.
I know this riff anywhere.
Like, it's the blind spot.
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum.
Bum, bum, bum, bum.
Bum, bum.
That's our jam.
Oh, he knows.
He knows that's his jam.
Bum.
Yeah, I could activate it.
Tokey activated it.
Oh my god, they- wait, they set up the rave lights!
Oh my, this is like the opening act.
This is like the main act right here.
They're like, all right.
I turn off the lights.
It's rave time.
Get up, everybody.
They actually got the lights out for this.
And help and help us.
I don't know.
Luckily, we have a holiday for Lunar New Year.
Send a vacation.
Yay!
Zero, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I don't know, but I don't.
Oh my god, it's coming.
The beach trap, it's coming, guys.
The drop, the drop, guys.
Oh my god, do you see the two people over there?
The two people.
Those two are like, five is so high.
They're like jamming out over there on the side.
Let's go.
And they're like, yeah, the drop!
I don't even know.
Yo, yeah, he's going crazy right now.
Most likely, you know, I think...
Oh.
Yeah!
Yay!
Game performance.
Get that game downloaded just for the soundtrack alone.
Good show.
Good show everybody.
Oh my god, is it somebody's birthday girl?
They got a kick for you!
They heard.
Ooh, okay.
Yeah, you tell me.
You tell me, you've been in the office.
The craft in the office has heard you.
It's your birthday cake!
It's actually amazing.
Oh, about to find out.
Oh, is that?
A PUBG Blindspot's opening.
No, I am good.
Now you can drop me.
I mean, don't drop the cash.
That was awkward.
So if you guys don't know, this is the lead developer.
This is the executive producer of PUBG Blindspot, making an
experience right here.
He's in job of the entire arcade.
team at pubg studios and he's currently also in charge of
developing pubg mindsports a 17 man team wait was he the guy
that was in our game the last pubg sponsor do you guys
remember that's him having the honors we had one of them we
played with one of them during our last sponsor ladies and
gentlemen that's how i don't know if it was him though this
entire journey has been for them if it was we killed him in
game and then he killed us too like multiple times because
he you know he is the
We got our one.
What have I done, by the way?
For Sheng Ming-gong.
Oh, wait, but wait.
There's more.
I was going to say there has to be more.
They said it was a 40-minute concert.
That's so long.
They've been working on this game, and that's been...
Eat the cake!
Oh, no cake break for them.
You're still on the clock.
They've started that.
all the iterating to start they're still on the clock no
kick for them that kind of works you know finding something
unique in terms of gameplay as well that's just pure
development life cycle and the last two years have brought
us to this point once again that was executive producer of
pubg blind spot leader of the arc team at pubg studios Sung
Myung Young
Yeah, they're not paid cake hours They're paid to rock And
roll Electronically No,
no, no, no, no, no, no Na na na na na.
Oh, look at how he's feeling it.
He's really feeling it right now.
The cowabunga, man.
Holy shit.
The lights go hard.
By the by the by the by the by the by.
By the by the.
By the by the by the.
Oh my god, do you see those two having a conversation?
How do you...
I was like, this is pretty loud.
The fact that these two could have a conversation while all
of this is going on.
I'm like, damn.
They're like next to the amps.
You see them?
They're like right next to the amps.
The
YAP does not stop.
They gotta finish their deadlines.
Is the drum even connected?
I'm pretty sure.
Look, all these cables around his drum.
They forgot to plug it in or something.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God, a mini drum.
He's like, step aside, little boy.
The master is here.
with his mini drum.
Needs more cowbell.
True, true.
Whoa.
Who's that?
Help me.
Welcome.
back welcome back and watch the concert with me oh wait i
will welcome back wait oh my god why is my discord hello oh
my god i didn't realize i was muted hello welcome back
surefore are you here to watch the concert with me sick
concerts one of the bad things is those in a way We got
trouble.
We're going to run as fast as possible.
Wait, really?
Damn, I was so late.
Wait, where does it say that?
Oh, okay.
They said, Doki, round up your little doggies and get them
in here now.
We can't do nothing around here, bro.
Oh, no.
The teacher called on us.
Reese, this is over, guys.
Back to class.
Back to class, everyone.
We had a substitute.
I was skipping.
I didn't give a shit.
You're going to skip class?
Oh, I'm going to tattle on you.
Oh, she's old.
Come on, man.
Mrs. Smith is going to find out.
That's right.
Where's your hall monitor pass?
Hell.
Yeah, that's right.
Now, where's your restroom pass, too?
I saw you running in that hallway.
I'm not.
restroom pass yeah i was a bad kid was it uh if they asked
me for a restroom pass grow up you're like 30 not you want
me a piece you want a piece of paper so i can shit like can
you use the vc server to us west i completely forgot to ask
about that last time bro we can't i can't do it twice in a
row bro they gotta it's not fair they're
gonna be like um no um why why you get special privileges
wait you can say because i'm the host that's true that's
true i get to change the server latencies because i'm the
host
okay guys i would really like it if we make it past the
first round because i have to stay till the end of the
tournament and i don't want to do the the walk of shame if i
get get knocked out oh I don't think that's already I'm
ready to wait no come on guys come on everyone just has to
win their ones and the twos that's such a good mentality I
got my and good luck everybody else yeah it worked it was
working remember the vtubers we beat that was the only team
we beat what do you mean it worked one out of three times
the percentage is not not on our side hit my ones dude hit
your ones me what i don't do that's not a good mentality
wait yeah that's true for the game our ones didn't work out
for you though hey i almost clutched them at the end of the
off i was getting mine oh i think they're swapping our
latencies oh my god it's normal now that's a good for real
badger say something yeah i'm here all right Oh, I think it
worked.
Yeah, he sounds fine.
Wait, suppose this team's not locked in?
Where's the process team?
They're probably getting yelled at separately.
Oh, yeah, they might be, like, at the principal's office
right now.
No, they're in the bathroom, like, smoking the shit right
now.
Do you guys really believe that this voice chat is
end-to-end encrypted?
I don't know.
I'm not sure about that.
Absolutely not.
What does that mean?
Our FBI agents are listening right now.
Which one's yours?
took a 3d scan of my face but i trust you wait did you
actually give your face no okay i was gonna say people are
using like it's a big deal it's not like they couldn't find
it on the internet if they wanted to you could just be like
just google it bro dude basically you didn't have to do the
age of verification it means they have all the data in other
social media platforms
oh yeah i was gonna say i already gave all my info to google
What else do they need from me?
All right, Discord, check it out.
You can just ask us what year we were born, and everybody's
honest, and they'll just tell you the truth, and clearly
we're all...
I never lied to Steam once.
That reminds me of that one clip of Gabe Newell talked
about.
It's a surprising amount of people are born in April, so
just no one changes the month.
That's awesome.
They only change the year.
No, ultimate game in speech is when he talks about realism.
that's true that's true it's unrealistic be like who gives a
fuck i've never cared oh wait how's the concert is it gas
yeah it's pretty yes it's an edm concert in the office are
they playing a sandstorm no they're playing their ocs yeah
yeah yeah they blind spot earlier i recognized that rift
anywhere oh the oh yeah yeah like i already have the game
launched i don't need to hear it yeah but you have you heard
it from heavenly though come on that's my headphones are
loud enough and we threw the mic like three times you know
it's much more impressive than this music that you got all
of those chords to go to the right places and none of them
glitched and everything's working that's pretty impressive
oh breaking everything that's a lot of words i just opened
the game up i just opened the game up you hear that man it
out bam bam bam bam bam but is everyone i lowered the
concert a little bit and then up them up more is that better
guys can you guys hear them is this because sure force
sometimes talks quietly but then when he's locked He's like
loud.
The drummer goes hard in the concert.
Has anyone even tried Zen yet?
Actually, I don't think anyone has, right?
Try what?
The new mouse?
No, not the new mouse.
The character Zen.
Oh, the Zen!
I don't think so.
I don't think I've seen anyone in this tournament play it
yet.
I don't think so.
I think they play actual good characters.
oh god no i feel like i feel like we're sleeping on zen i
try it they have a sticky grenade launcher yeah but then
there's friendly fire yes i'm pretty sure none of us are
gonna accidentally yeah wait wait does the barbed wire
damage you no it like it makes noise it makes noises so you
know if anyone's like flanking to like certain spots and
slows yeah yeah and make sure I saw that on Twitter.
They're calling us a Fortnite lobby ad team.
But we kind of are a Fortnite lobby man.
We are pretty much, yeah.
Yeah, I feel like this is the only time we're all together
here.
Where is this guy looking where he's finding these comments?
Smash Bros.
ass team, bro.
Everyone's here.
This guy said, I don't want to use Twitter.
And now he's talking about people calling us Fortnite lobby.
No, I absolutely use Twitter.
I just don't use it till the end of the day.
I save that dopamine for the evening.
Yeah, he saves the doom scrolling.
One hour before you wake, or not before you wake up, one
hour before you go to sleep, one hour after you wake up, and
then that's it.
Also, could you guys hear them earlier when the concert
music was a bit too loud, guys?
I wasn't sure.
Were you guys able to hear everybody?
I'm just like, iPad kid.
There's got to be more here.
Wow, wow.
What a performance.
One more time.
No, but what if you just had a kid?
It's so much fun.
Then you could just go upstairs and just like, he will grab
your face and squeeze it not knowing that that hurts like
that's so much more fun than fooling around on a phone right
I don't think I'll ever get to feel that man I don't think
I'll have a kid oh my god what happened I'm physically
unking testicular torsion on stream without getting in
trouble I'm physically unable to because I am lopsided the
best way I could oh my condolences bro I'm Sorry, man.
I'm so sorry.
Yeah, you know, one side exists.
It's like, you know, sort of, instead of like two ping pong
balls, he has one.
No, it doesn't work.
They're just dead?
They're just dead there?
Where does the Pico?
I have the one.
And that's it.
Wait, but where does the Pico?
Well, doctor did not do a good job.
were um untangling and they have accidentally hit something
he wasn't supposed to hit turns out that you could sue for
that didn't know i was just so excited i couldn't have kids
i was like hell yeah man no but even with that type of thing
they're using ways to rectify it yeah you can't you just
like glue it back together no it's gone they threw it away
they threw the entire sack away how long has it been i still
have the sack oh so you have one ball i have one ball it
doesn't work yeah but that one ball has like no kids in
there it's just yeah heavenly can we just like there's like
no ammo dog how do you actually cut it off the doctor like
five minutes late when he explained so they did cut it off i
just twisted and then when it twisted it was twisted bad
enough that i had to do surgery instead of them just like
untwisting it because you can't just untwist it but mine was
bad and when they finished everything the doctor fucked up
and they told me the doctor fucked up and i went okay all
right cool and that's and then they were just like really
and i was like yeah i didn't want kids anyway how did you
tangle it up that badly like what did you do just move
around and i'll say it can happen anytime yeah when you feel
like it's kind of slippery it can be a little a little
buggery down there yeah it was probably all messed up you
know there's not good wire man turn your leg the wrong way
in your in your foxta yeah so it can happen at any time at
any point in your life anytime yeah right now that's yeah
you can get it right now pubg blind spot you stand up it
bounces the wrong way everybody click on the link below guys
that's that's like rng that's like you fucking lost the rng
of antagonizing it it's like a it's like a gamble but you
don't want to hit it it's like it's like so low that can
happen but it eventually happens it's the evil ass gotcha no
you could have a stroke you could have a pulmonary embolism
like any any one of these things could happen yeah what is
that pulmonary embolism it's basically like a little
explosion inside of one of your veins and it's very not good
for you that sounds cool that's you can get in your you can
get in your had a freaking explosion in this it just it just
basically a blockage that causes like a little explosion oh
my god new fear unlocked yeah exactly so like yeah you're
really giving your fans a show by saying these are all these
little tiny low likelihood things you are giving my fans and
before those things happen you should download pubg blind
spot and enjoy the time playing that first that's why you
gotta flip the coin and look at the other side and it's
beautiful that you're every day normal and none of that is
randomly killing you exactly except for heavenly he lost the
ball but that's fine because with it i was able to still
play pubg oh yeah that's true he still gets to enjoy the
lovely experience playing pubg blind spot right now and you
too can join us as well by clicking on the link pinned in
the chat and in the description below but now he has a have
you that's saying the dokey covered all 2000 of your ears at
the same time so you didn't hear it all right i believe that
no you know what you know what i'm about to say it i i am
irrationally angry that dropouts magazine on her chris
vector is 20 rounds that's what i'm saying it's like that
rpm gone instantly but that's okay blind spot has 14 other
characters that you can pick from if you play right now
exactly in the game i ain't doing it again i'm not even
sponsored i'm not doing an ad read i'll do one yeah i can't
okay check out fanatic she's got a different type of weapon
that is equally as powerful as the f2000 called the p90 and
it's got 50 bullets
you can play Claris and don't have to reload at all.
Yeah!
When you have a hundred bullets in your mag.
Wait, I'm still gonna find a way to get rid of all of them.
I'm still gonna reload.
I literally shoot like five shots.
I'm like, reload!
I think we're gonna start playing in another 30 minutes if
you look at the team chat.
Oh, wait, what are they saying?
Oh, you're right.
Okay, yeah, team, it's okay, guys.
It's only three people interviewed instead of four, so it'll
be like 10 minutes yeah we're just hanging out yeah hanging
out we're the fortnight lobby oh i know how i'm gonna pass
the time my recommended because i clicked on your stream is
now i'm han solo by gokeeper i gotta watch this i'm watching
han solo and not not the other one it was the new one again
oh girlfriend yeah girlfriend i thought it's called someone
else you should be watching that one by pubg blind spot yo
this is actually gas i was just just ready to make fun of
you what you're really good yeah it's like it's very
faithful to the original out for the lion's share of the
prize i even have like the connect overlay and everything on
day number one day number two is about to kick underway and
there's a lot though these teams need to compete oh my gosh
day number two guys this looks like it takes a lot of work
to pull This was really impressive.
Oh, yeah, it did.
I wasn't if there was a third day.
Oh, here we go.
I don't want to go with like the first, the second day is
just like one game.
And then the third day is the finals.
Yo, the third day I'm sure sure four is not going to be.
Something keeps happening.
First, I didn't wake up and then my phone died.
I think I would just die and not make it on the third day.
Literally any excuse to be valid.
Yeah, I want to go to Target at that day at that time.
Has already screwed themselves a big back.
mark yep everyone is looking for the money we're 15 000
obviously up for grab you mentioned oh my god wait there's
kill leader i forgot i don't think any of us are in the
running for kill leader i hear yeah most kills in the
tournament gets a thousand dollars by the way the entire
tournament that was a thing yeah and i killed my own
teammates for no reason what i could wait no it does not
count you're not in the leaderboard okay well i only killed
i only killed my teammates twice only twice no i never ran a
third time i forgot i accidentally killed him in the way
once and you killed sure for it once too yeah i don't
remember his name but i remember there was one dude that was
playing a lot of dropout and was actually very gas yesterday
i don't remember his name because you might be out but i
remember he was like hard carrying his team you were getting
a lot of kills all right so if we kill him then we should So
we're facing that team we face.
Just kill him, dude.
Yeah, just kill him for it.
It's just that easy.
And we all shoot him at once.
We should do the strat that killed sure for when one was
crouching and the other one was like standing.
Did they can like do a fight?
Please join LaVey.
Don't say the number like yesterday.
Don't say the number, please.
All right.
Game time.
1738.
Oh, my God.
Me playing for us in 2016.
of 97?
no it's wait is it 97?
is that the fight of 69?
no you're not a real fan of them.
yeah we attacking defending um we um we are um we are Or
attack.
Or attack.
Hello.
Can you hear me?
Yeah.
Yep.
Oh, Doki, are you ready for your interview?
Yeah, I am.
Okay.
Thank you for your confirmation.
All right.
They're gonna drag me up there soon.
Wonder when that's gonna happen.
It can happen at any moment.
Yeah, guys, let's start.
Damn, there's somebody in here that speaks Korean English.
English and Chinese that's super impressive yeah even even
oh no it's happening again oh
no oh no I think it's just you man oh I think it's just me
with gig up gig down and like a long stream that only gods
could dream of owning yeah it's definitely me thank you
Discord so what is different in our stream I wonder oh I
have it boosted out the with pink crystals because I'm like
that.
I forgot about the boost.
The boost may be giving us perks this whole time.
Oh, I need some of that.
But the boost might be giving us perks.
But I just chose to bust out my wrist to just boost this
server for no reason.
I don't know.
Just get it one boost, come on, one boost won't hurt.
Oh wait, can't you just move like the boost that you already
have so you don't have to spend money?
Yeah, so there's no one else that's going to exist after
tomorrow.
What the heck?
No, it's going to exist in here.
We're gonna hang out tomorrow, right?
We're gonna play blind spot tomorrow?
I'm gonna be busy.
Yeah, yeah, I gotta go to Target tomorrow.
I'm gonna be sick that day.
What?
No, but...
But Shurfer will be there.
When you go to Target, Doki, oh, I'm going to Target exactly
when you wanna hang out with me.
But Shurfer will be there, see?
He hasn't said anything.
He's gonna be there.
He's your best friend.
Shurfer, are you gonna be there?
Yeah.
oh all right fine fine i will close my discord and i'll run
it as an administrator to see if it oh damn he's pulling out
the admin powers
whoa okay apparently prod is uh subbing in for the pickle
guy whoever yeah whoever was pickup that's the guy that dc'd
and then we took advantage of it no i think subrosa was the
one that no it was pica he dc'd and then we clicking we were
like let's keep going i think you mean we played the game
within the parameters of the rules yeah yeah yeah did
someone say something to me i was getting food yeah you're
gonna play this game with me tomorrow right this one yeah no
what i thought You've got to go back.
You've got to check out the VODs because you've got to
understand what's going on.
But we're getting those.
Someone's trying to take back their channel.
Don't keep her.
Hello.
You said to us yesterday that you only wanted to win one
match where you got more than one.
You got yourself through to the final.
Big GG's.
Well done.
Look, what are you bringing to the table this evening,
though?
Because you've got to get through the same final and you've
got to get back a win.
So I told my team, I was like, guys, we have to make it past
this round because I have to still stream.
we get knocked out.
So please, I do not want to do the walk of shame and
continue to be live after getting knocked out of my own
tournament.
So please.
And then my team was like, well, just gotta get your ones.
And I was like, guys, we have to have a better strategy than
getting our ones, guys.
No, you're right.
You just gotta get your twos.
And I'm like, okay, that's fine, I guess.
So that's our strategy.
We each gotta get our ones, and then we'll win, I guess.
Well, we saw you in strategy.
I was listening back to your Vardin.
In the breaks, you were talking about strategy.
Look, final question for me, though.
Are you changing anything up today, though, coming into the
semi-finals?
Or is it just about getting your ones and getting a kill and
moving on?
Apparently, we're just going to try and get our ones, and
then we'll see how that goes.
Maybe we'll adapt on the fly.
We'll see.
That's the beauty of our team.
We don't know what we're doing.
And if the team doesn't know what we're doing, then we
won't.
win I guess like if they don't know what we're doing well
look Doki bird I'm gonna take it I've got a love and leave
you because you need to get ready you need to get yourself
in a lobby so best of luck we'll see you though on the
battleground shortly get out of here go do some prep work
with the team and get them Jida yeah no problem thank you
again guys GG's bye bye bye getting the ones mark getting
the you can't hop on them forever hey guys I'm back I got
attracted to the conversation what about rem what we even
say huh i don't even remember what conversation oh yeah that
we were talking about anything interesting apparently i'm
kill leader oh you're kill leader right now yeah apparently
i'm kill leader well you guys of all the team kills wait
like on our team or like overall because you have to be
overall oh shit okay well you keep getting the kills And
then heavenly is number is number number three.
34 kills.
Wait, oh, where am I?
Where am I?
Yeah.
I think there's a separate page.
I think I think there's a separate page for that.
Like what about what about badger?
Is he on the top?
I think there's another page for that one.
You're just gonna just skin me alive like that when you know
the numbers not that high.
I gotta drag you down with me, bro.
know at least if we lose it's because our kill leader isn't
getting his three exactly if we had two of the top 10 top
three kill leaders and we're still losing like okay i have i
want to say secret but we have to like it's either we when
we lose or we win the whole thing a secret that i am so
surprised that i'm kill leader with my with my current
condition that i just learned yesterday because i should not
i should not be what rsi What the fuck is that?
What's RSI?
That's what you get when your hand is hurting.
Oh no, it's worse.
You know what, should I just say no?
I fuck it, whatever.
Yeah, apparently my wrist has been fractured for like six
weeks.
Yeah.
Fractured?
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah, apparently I've been playing with a fractured wrist
this entire time.
I'm ranked 12.
You're?
Let's go!
Doki's rank 17.
Don't shut the fuck up.
I'm confused.
No, Badger's ranked 13 right behind me.
Bruh.
Okay, but all right.
So, so if any of us is kill leader, which obviously won't be
me, I'm not including there, but I don't think I could catch
up, but you guys can win $1,000 individually if you get kill
leader.
I don't think I want to even give him wire transfer
instructions for my corporation.
I'll just give it to you.
I'm just going to down them and let Gomez finish them off.
You guys are going to be dead.
No, you're going to.
But he needs the 1K for his surgery.
No, no.
I'm pretty sure I'm getting a cast.
I'm pretty sure that's what's going to happen.
How did you even fracture that, John?
I went to Guatemala and I slipped and I fell on my wrist.
I thought you were going to stop there.
No.
Oh, no, I went to Guatemala.
You're supposed to say you put something on your wrist so
heavy and diamond encrusted.
that it hit the ground and you fractured your wrist.
I had too much ice on my wrist.
It was too heavy, bro.
You bust down your wrist way too hard.
It kind of, no, I'm not going to say it.
No, it's just, I fell and I just like, like all my way on
it.
You're literally knuckle dragging on the ground when you
walk.
Can't even have my wrist in the sun, bro.
I'll get blinded by all this ice.
Oh my God.
I thought I thought my whole condition was just was was
carpal tunnel that was wrong yeah you just have a fractured
bone in your in your arm dumbass dumbass American hospital
just somehow missed it I don't know how they did but didn't
you didn't they give you the also oh sure for ready up in
case the teacher comes in again um they're typing right now
they're literally
jump i have my game alt tab so i don't hear the
it's like the same three second loop
ah guys we got this yeah we make it but we make it i don't
have i don't have to do the walk of shame how are you four
positions lower than me and i don't even play video games
will you play more more of these types of games than me what
are you saying you have a gun three months without playing a
video game and doki somehow below me no no doki has a gun
with 100 because i keep reloading is that what you want to
know i keep reloading yeah yeah you gotta get you gotta get
one of those key claws and just remove your archie just
don't don't let it be there i shoot like one mat like one
like 10 shots and i was like i should reload i don't think i
have enough bullets this is the best of three or best of
five best of three i think like finals is best of five let
me check well if we make it i can check all right i'm just
saying right now it is a very high likelihood but let's say
i win
$500 for this wrist surgery, $4.95 for unlimited C4 cans,
for sure, for.
Yay!
And we'll buy Dokey a McChicken and have it as soon as we
get to it.
Oh, yeah!
Yay!
I don't know if you wanted that McChicken.
I know you wanted that McChicken.
The dollar value hasn't been the thing for like 10 years.
I don't know if you know that.
Hey, McChicken's still under $5.
It's like, it's like three.
That's still enough.
With some change.
the good old days of the dollar menu oh my god right now
anytime i do something wrong anytime i do something wrong
heavenly's like you will give me 20 in a mcchicken or else
i'm telling twitter like twitter what what does he have on
you nothing
all right y'all ready to win this yeah let's get our game
i'm so ready I ran out of that.
Oh, did you take me off your brace?
I took off my brace.
Oh, my God.
It was power level.
Fun K.
Oh, I'm making myself more vulnerable to making my wrist
more damaged.
Let's go.
Yeah, but you get $1,000.
The potential to get $1,000.
Yes.
I need that one grand.
I need it.
They're going to pull a fast one on you and tell you that
it's 1,000 Korean won.
I'm thinking.
I've never seen that much.
much money before wait hold on how much is that i think chat
would know i think it's seven to one oh we're attacking but
the by the way it's 144 guys same as yesterday outskirts
bust right in that thing and just win all right okay i
didn't realize the game was starting and it chose a random
character should i should we do what what that other team
was doing where we go wilson and goldberg chair i feel i
feel like that i feel like we have to do that sure supposed
to be secret lady all right who wants who wants to be what
you can still switch at the bottom hit agents you can switch
all right you right you're right yeah all right i have the
shield all right you have the bomb so you should give it to
one of us 10.
are you right i don't know how i just pinged i got it all
right i'm ready i'm putting motion oh yo you have to shoot
it by the way i'm i just don't want dokey to step in front
of my barrel All right, I'm going straight to point.
Go and be, go and be.
Oh wait, it's open.
Oh, okay.
What?
Motion sensor.
Good motion.
Here, Lord had us.
I'm gonna sit here in the corner.
Yeah, that works.
Where I hear.
There's no, you can be wall banging.
That is not right.
I know.
Right here.
The most timing of timing ever.
I knew I should have just fucking held that angle.
They got motion.
Okay.
Come on, reload, reload my gun.
Oh, I got my gun.
I got my gun.
I'm left.
I got you.
Oh, my god.
There's one more way.
Two more, two more, two more.
Let's go.
Motion!
What the hell?
I was picking my nose for a while.
I was like checking out my M4.
I was doing a lot of stupid shit.
I should have shot them one.
You guys don't want to know what happened to me.
You don't want to know what happened to me.
I heard something on my flank, and I was holding the angle,
and then as soon as I move to jump through the window, he
starts peaking.
It wasn't even like he heard me moving.
It was like, it was the exact moment I decided to stop
holding the angle.
He peaked.
I was so used to the guy I played yesterday that my full
auto gun was semi-auto for a bit there.
So I was like, man, I'm missing way too many shots.
What the hell going on?
Okay, now, how about this?
How about this?
Now, instead of going, because now they're going to
anticipate it.
Okay.
Now we go, now we go A.
go let's go down here yeah actually wait no they're gonna
reinforce that's a long that's a long hallway that's a long
yeah yeah but yeah that's true they won't see it coming well
they'll hear it coming oh true so let's go this way wait
where wait why do i have the top in so we just just rush in
this way this way this way this way i'm ready wait where are
we going i can put a camera By the way, guys, I am playing
for no kills.
I'm not getting that one grand.
I got the juice.
It's something we all want to hit.
I'm, we're shooting.
Ready, whatever.
All right, let's go.
I'm shielding.
Walking in.
Making space.
Motion!
Walking in.
Walking in through A.
Wait, wait, wait.
He's over here.
Oh, my.
Okay, nice, really nice.
I walk, walk, walk.
I have my shield.
My RNG sniper rifle missed.
No, you have to zoom in again, remember?
Come on.
A's open.
Go get him!
Go!
Hey, hey, hey!
I'm throwing up!
Behind him!
Oh no!
Behind him, instead!
What?!
You're defusing the bomb!
I have a shield.
Wait, wait, wait, hold on.
Wait, wait.
It's clear, it's clear, you're good, you're good.
Okay, going.
That's fine.
You're gonna probably fire.
Just be careful.
That's fine, that's fine.
You have another rooster?
They're halfway through the bomb.
They're halfway through.
2v1.
Wow!
Just get us that one drag!
This is opiates.
This is so stupid.
Maybe I should hate you.
This is opiates.
I'll turn on my teammates purple.
I mean, yeah, bro.
I should be gassing everybody up.
Just so that way y'all can win.
Let's go kill leaders!
I tried to wall bang someone.
It didn't work.
And then he just randomly shot through the wall.
kill me.
It's going to work eventually.
I would have had two freaking kills by now.
Okay, do we do the same thing again?
I kind of like landings that are outskirts to like bent
hallway.
See bent hallway?
That looks like a fairly...
Oh, I like that.
I like that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And we push through...
We go...
Bless you.
We...
Then we go through supply room.
Okay.
the fuel storage we go and then we go to a second a second
thing didn't come out though yeah i don't even hear it then
we go to the fly room okay yeah yeah so we wish which is
this way it's over here yeah we're all the way around i'm
thinking here are loud ass stomping good good he's gotta be
let them know we're coming i also didn't know i could reload
this thing so i've just been like i've thought it was a
one-year go go go okay you gotta get out of the way when i'm
fired Go on, go on.
Go on, go on.
There's two, there's two.
There's one to your right.
Oh, what?
There's one here.
There's one here, guys.
What?
Did I get shot in the back?
We'll get one.
Okay, okay.
Oh.
Good try.
I got your kills though, you guys.
Okay.
They were so close.
They were like, there was one on our level.
Probably because they heard us fucking stomping across the
map.
No, they're stream stomping.
Okay, we literally were we just like put you with gunfire
down.
I'm pretty sure someone shot me in the fucking back because
there's no way that guy killed me in that patch.
That was me.
I got a little silly.
Oh, geez.
We should have took him the long row.
Oh, fuck, I didn't realize we were defending.
Okay, wait, who's defending B?
Who's gonna work on him?
I'm just gonna put on.
I'll do B.
This here.
Do that here.
I'm going to throw this here.
I'm putting my razor wire here.
That cover.
Remember, don't forget about your barricades.
No, I can already tell Gomez is a huge brain.
What did I do?
You have a huge brain.
You just put all that stuff in really good spots.
Dude, I woke up really good today.
I'm ready.
Motion.
Foam deployed.
Ready more than I could be.
Then I'm going to put...
Wait.
We're going A.
Wait, that's where I am.
That's where I am.
I'm gonna put a wall like this.
I basically set up...
Using the music for cover.
So that means they have to use the guy with the hammer,
because I took the other guy.
So they can't blow the walls over.
So we can shoot him while he's doing it.
Oh, motion, motion, motion here.
Motion, motion, motion.
They got motion.
I have a wall there.
It's fine.
They're taking it super slow.
Me when I remembered I could barricade.
things oh they broke through oh they're trying to kill me
hold on hold give me give me a vision give me vision all the
way waiting i give vision yep are they going around oh
they're going around there's two coming on me right now yeah
you're by yourself bad you're careful that's okay right here
right here i see him watch out for the grenade right here
got one nice watch behind us wait behind us behind us behind
us behind us oh she got me she beat me I was trying to
reload They walked through the gas For some reason Oh my god
What I didn't see them Round fired
Are you behind you behind you Come on you Come to you
Shefford What you didn't kill him No He didn't kill him I
saw like going That was like an awkward run around I saw it
He like perfectly Perfectly Ringed around me Yeah I'm so sad
The wall I was trying to fling through Was reinforced And I
was like Well I can't blow it up They'll hear me I'm so sad.
Oh no, it's close now.
No, Shrevear, I shit you not.
He like perfectly LOS'd me the entire way.
That was trying to peek him.
That's sad.
I got pinched.
I mean, I didn't see, I didn't realize that he got an angle
on that area too.
Also I have an idea.
Now that you're holding that spot, Shrevear, I have an idea.
What if I, what if I wall off the other off angle so then
you can just perm a fart on him?
I can only have two farts.
No, but like this here.
So like if he wants the peek over here, they have to break
this door and then they have to also break it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And Lord has you can...
Yeah, this is the good.
This is good.
And then we wall off this.
So then you have like a perfect far angle.
It's actually perfect.
All right.
It came from here.
So I'm putting a motion here.
And then I'll put a motion here.
I'm going to fence up this.
We're a bit split up here.
Oh, I think they're walking by me.
By yourself.
They're all there on him, on him.
There's no flight ground here.
Oh, I can make one.
Foam deployed.
Don't hear any.
Oh, they've got names on me.
Watch behind us.
Okay.
They're close.
They crossed?
Oh, they're here!
I didn't...
Right here.
Where I ping?
I'm ready for it.
Oh, you saw me.
You got him?
Go on, go on.
I got him.
That's here.
Oh, two more over there.
Wait, wait, wait.
Three?
I remember you could jump in this.
I jumped over the...
Last one here.
Two more.
One more.
Yeah, right here.
I think you asked your place, though.
He asked the place.
Yeah, so he's at the way from the place.
Yeah, I'll try to walk away from you.
one sure for that makes noise by the way yeah that still
makes noise but again just keep making noise and scared him
because then he has to come look for the noise you know the
badger shoots another egg wait badger that he's gonna be
like maybe walking through a or and he probably will you
know just listen for the plant he has to plant so either he
plays team deathmatch or plants but he can't do both throw
in the gadget good nice throw in the those last like 15
seconds that's really good here i'll just throw in the
gadget okay make a decision oh my my way my way he hit me oh
no yes good bait good bait oh my god i got the trade your
baby baby baby baby baiting baiting all right now we do the
same exact thing We hold that one choke area because I think
the walls in the in the barbed wire for a or for b They
can't walk in at all like in that area just because of how
much Uh badger can just kind of like use his molotovs if
they try to walk in He's gonna wall them off.
Try to save him Yeah, brain brain activity is good today.
Oh, we're thinking here You might put I'll save one motion
sensor just in case actually
put it here just in case i die all right you want me to i'm
i'm gonna barricade this wall right here it's fine two walls
there i'm gonna put a wall like we did last time like my way
my way my way was your way okay oh i see i see two there's
like all of them over by b Yeah.
Here, I see him.
Watch out.
Gas round fired.
Want a wallet?
I gassed it.
You're over here.
They're hitting this wall too.
Just be patient.
Yeah, I'm making sure we don't get fined.
Oh, they scanned me.
I got detected.
I have an idea.
Oh my god, Badger.
That's an insane kill.
That's their entry.
Their entry is dead.
Watch out, Badger.
Don't do it.
How does he know who his entry is?
It's a shield guy.
Oh, I hear someone walking far left.
Yeah, you tried, bitch.
By you.
I hear someone wrong.
Easy kill.
I'm either down.
There you go.
Oh my god.
Oh.
Go come get me.
Oh, he's one there.
He's one there.
Uh, they're, they're in between A and B.
Yep.
Gomez sees where they are.
He's in the corner.
Yeah, he is.
Watch behind us.
Oh.
He's going outside.
Oh, he's walking.
My, my sense is here.
I'm here.
Outside that wall, the sticky wall.
One enemy.
The last one's really low.
I'm so mad.
Do some characters have more health?
Triple top armor than other.
I have no idea.
I think it's just the guns, right?
Maybe the guns just do more damage.
How's the vector loose to a freaking AK?
He hit his shots.
I feel like your gun is- How do you know Gomez did that with
156 ping?
I don't know.
Yeah, well, you're looking at 31.6% accuracy.
Acquacy?
Okay.
Oh, accuracy?
I was not familiar with your game.
No, no, princess.
It will alpha's here.
Oh, yeah.
There has to be different armor values.
So this is the sure forest line.
I forgot to read it out for everybody.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
My sword glistens in the night as that moonlight shines on
the edge of my blade.
a bird heard in the distance just to position the last beat
of your heart oh hello hey yeah team subrosa chose hospital
a so team joki can't please choose a side all right let's
side you guys what i like attack again okay yeah yeah attack
oh no wait hold on attack attack attack attack attack no no
attack we're attack all right we don't have to move starting
with attack yeah yeah okay thank you good luck guys thank
you all right the rest of my sword glistens in the night as
the moonlight shines on the edge of my blade a bird heard in
this distance just positioning the last beat of your heart
one last cherry blossom falls from the tree on your chest
where you can finally rest that was his one line that's
awful man that's awful man what do you mean that's That's
amazing.
That's a four word limit.
I don't want to say anything.
Was that chat GPT?
Yeah, I was told four word limit.
That was the chat GPT.
No, I don't use AI.
That's all him.
All right.
So Heavenly, wait, did Heavenly tell you guys what he wrote?
Please just go ahead and tell them.
It's like eating something.
No, no.
No, the chicken thing I made up, that was just gaslighting.
That's not real.
This was...
Hey, uh, Doki Bird, ready up.
All right.
Here we go.
step aside princess a real alpha is here i think i was
hoping i would be horrible because now i'm like 30 kills
with that imagine that you get kill leader need to display
that there's like our kill leader is heavenly oh hello oh
sorry guys uh are you guys ready for set two yep yes we are
okay thank you all right we're ready we're ready we got the
plan this can potentially be last game guys is it best of
three yeah and then we go to the finals yes then we win yeah
we win we get more money by the way i didn't notice how op
the guy with the shield's gun is that fire so that's why
that's why people kept running that guy my vector doesn't
seem to fire fast at all What is up with you and this gun?
I don't know.
You should have saw what happened when I was lasering that
guy and I lost him an AK and pissing me off.
Maybe you should play the AK guy.
Well, my gun has 20 bullets as well.
So what's your excuse?
My excuse is they have to have different armor values or
something.
I think that's coke.
I'm pretty sure that's coke.
Man.
Oh, wait.
Wait, this is a perfect push.
Why don't we go outskirts into into here?
Okay.
And break the, oh, wait, no, wait, that's a big wall.
We don't have a breacher.
I guess what?
Wait, no, you are a breacher.
Aren't you?
No, I know you're not.
I was gas, but no, I can breach.
No, no, no, no, no.
On.
What if we just go through?
We don't really need the juice.
The juice isn't really helping.
We can just go through the control room pre-treatment and
then in.
I can breach.
I can go the breacher.
All right.
Okay, fine.
Yeah, we go there.
We go there.
All right.
Are we breaching?
So I'm on the other side of the map.
It changed my spawn.
That's kind of epic.
Everyone, let's just wait.
Let's just wait.
Make them anticipate.
Okay, okay.
True, true, true.
I love team.
Wait, wait.
Someone grab the bomb.
Not me.
Wait, they're just shooting shit.
They're breaking doors.
Just hopping.
I think they hear us.
All right.
We're going right here, right?
I'm throwing my motion.
Okay.
Shoot it up in first.
All right.
Break it.
Okay.
Break this wall.
Oh, wait.
There's nothing to throw it and then hit E.
That is a lot.
It may not.
Let me reload this.
Okay.
I thought I was ready.
I forgot.
Hold on.
Three, two, one.
Go, go, go.
Break through it.
I can't reach it.
Oh, you got gas.
You got gas.
It's preaching.
Someone looking back.
Hold on.
Someone look behind.
It's just in case.
Get the heroin shot.
Ready?
Three, two, one.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Okay.
Gas, gas.
shot the gas and it put it on my shield.
I did not know that was possible.
Now you know.
That's kind of funny.
Huge.
I'm super low though.
Oh my god.
Three.
Oh, I got you.
I was super low.
I have one HP.
You got this.
No.
One was crouched.
One was standing up.
No, we need to do that.
I kind of forgot about the gas thing, man.
No, no, no, no.
A very big FYI here is...
Yeah, it can put...
that you can none of us can engage but the front person or
else we're friendly firing each other yeah i'm pretty sure
someone fucked me up no every time every time i want you to
shoot i'm usually crouching so that's that's usually well
it's more so the people behind the person behind you are
shooting one more time then i'm going back to my character
and we're just going to split up and do the crazy stuff we
normally do okay okay well i didn't i didn't know where to
break that wall i'm not gonna lie that breach charge takes
way too long that's too long we yeah we should use the
hammer guys then use a portable i think this guy is a sticky
launcher no that doesn't break walls you got to use the the
dude with the ak the the goggles yeah yeah goggles that guy
but just be careful one guy's not with us right now one
guy's not with the wall right i'm just gonna instantly die
yes also well no but also don't stand near him when he does
it does do a A lot of damage.
Wait, we just busted his window.
Wait, let's just busted his window.
Okay, holding up my shield.
Oh, very far, very far.
Walking.
Checking inside.
They used the impact.
Checking corners.
Nothing here.
They're trying to wall bang on front point.
Right here.
Close.
Shield ready.
Okay, fire.
Oh, I took it.
I took it.
My bad, my bad.
Okay, Doki is alone, by the way.
Yeah, yeah, that's fine.
That's fine.
They're right here, right here.
Watch out.
I have a motion.
I'm checking right.
They're close, close, close.
Lord, head out.
Watch out.
They forwarded.
Okay, it's fine.
Do you have another, do you have another breach?
Hold on.
I can engage from there.
I can engage from here.
Okay.
Three, two, one.
Good.
He's right underneath there.
Walkin.
got shot in the back i can be res i can be resed lord head
house is one hb oh i can be resed hey hey one minute or he's
making his way to you he's making free anyone want to help
me i would have helped you i just didn't realize i walked to
the wrong team i yeah got to be free oh we should have
walked with doki guys okay we'll flank them then doki Okay,
I swear to God.
I'm back.
You need a couple more.
We're dead.
I do not have any more nays, by the way.
Oh, I see him.
I see him.
You killed them all here.
What are these fuck ass vents, man?
Oh, what?
No, there was one more behind me.
Oh, are you fucking kidding me?
The fuck?
So you just walked in to be free?
Yeah, walked in to be free.
Well, like, show us how your entire team went to the fight
in that fucking vent.
Yeah, do that again.
We could just do that again.
give me the bomb and i'll just walk to be free right wait
the c9 strat well that's op yeah we just did the thing i did
yesterday where i made all yeah i'll do make all the noise
and then doki just sneaks around but just don't die just
don't die because then they're all gonna rush to the point i
was just lucky because they didn't want to push me okay yeah
i literally waked like from here and then i like slowly
walked up to be by the way i think just to be sure i'm gonna
whenever i walk How do I do it?
They're here.
I'm gonna, I'm gonna want someone to smoke this side.
On the left.
I feel like emergency room spawn is ass because you can't do
anything in this entire hallway.
Like this entire wall is just dead.
Yeah, let's go askers then.
Yeah.
I need you guys to make noise.
Make some noise.
Cause I have the bomb.
If I die with the bomb, that'd be very awkward.
I'll just, I'm gonna wait until you guys come out.
I'm in.
Are you in?
No, I wouldn't hit you.
I'm a good shot.
We're checking every corner.
When you walk in.
All right.
Walking.
Walking here.
Wait, you should probably check the inside here.
There you go.
Okay.
Walking here.
If you want.
Here.
Walking here.
Back up.
I'm going to blow the walls open.
Yep.
Grenade.
I'm going to shoot that.
Oh, my grenade blew up.
The.
No, I'm so pissed What happened on me on me on me on me He
shot my he shot my ass here directly ahead of us Emily.
I'm reloading.
I'm getting out of the way He downed me.
I downed him.
Okay Let's crouch.
Hey, it's a 2v2 1v1 3v1 if you if you run don't you're
behind them No, I almost he's one he's one.
He's actually Fuck he's crashed.
He's crashed.
He has my bomb Okay, he's all you have to do is tickle him
He has a bomb, so he's got a guard for it.
One.
You're kicked out of scans.
Yeah, but the problem is...
I don't know where he is.
Maybe in this room?
In there on your right?
How many scans do you have?
One.
I was mostly...
Just walk through, be a big boss about it.
Don't even scare it, bro.
If you clear left the left room, can't you just...
The thing is, that slows him down, so...
There's only a vent in there.
Well...
Just walk through the barbed wire.
Let him know.
It doesn't hurt.
Just makes noise.
Let him know you were there and you're ready to kill.
Yeah!
Oh, he...
You dropped him.
Oh, he's running away.
Do you go on B?
He went on B.
Yeah, he's in B.
He's just gonna... Oh, nice!
Oh, he has no...
He has no...
Just make noise and let him know you're ready to kill.
That's the strat.
So can you explain when somebody's crouching, you have to
hit control or you can shoot?
Or you crouch as well.
If you crouch, then you can just shooting at him.
Okay.
If you crouch, then they're already shooting.
If you're still standing though.
Yeah.
Right?
You do.
You just hit him on the crouch.
You want me to grab the bomb again and do the same thing or?
We're defending.
Oh, we're defending.
Oh, whoops.
I didn't even notice.
All right.
Why my characters look indifferent?
It's weird.
Boom and coming.
We're the best.
Where the frick is I?
I can't wall this.
Razor wires down.
I put razor wire here.
Can my walls be put on on on surfaces that are not the
floor?
Or no?
You don't know.
Or is it just bounce?
I don't want to test it.
Put this here.
I don't even know where to.
I guess like here.
and then phone wall now we barricaded that whole area yeah
they watch out enemies here no they're here window i hear
breaking over here
Oh, they're breaching.
Oh, they know we're here.
They know we're here.
Yeah, I'm detected.
I gasped.
Okay, I got gasped again.
Wait, no, that was a, oh, that was a, that was a scan.
That's a scan.
Yeah.
They're throwing him here.
I was hitting someone.
I'm dead.
Oh, no, no.
You rose me.
I gasped again.
Sure, sure.
Sure.
I'm holding the angle.
I got you.
I got one.
No, I'm coming my way, somebody's crouch.
I got one, too.
Okay, that's cool.
They're all pushed down.
I got, yeah, I got.
Should be one more.
Watch one here.
I got two.
Oh, there's one more.
To your left, to your left.
Yeah, right, sorry.
That's one, there's one.
No, he was one.
He was crouching.
I swear, that's the reason that I missed him too.
He was one.
I feel like you got to be crouched all the time because
people forget to hit control.
I'm holding it.
I just be holding control.
Yeah, I also feel like I was holding it, not working oh
that's so close i don't know why i tried run jumping when
the grenade was next to me so i just i just blew up right
next to it dude guys what what i just saw the best news ever
what is it androgyny has assembled the most catastrophic mog
alliance of psl history to avenge convicular dude it's the
best day He's effort.
Can I get a translation?
Yeah, I was like, what?
Oh, I see we just aren't keeping up with current events.
That's fine.
The current events of what?
Dude, Kavicular got brutally framed log by the ASU frat
leader.
Were you not there, dude?
What's a frag?
Motion sensor?
I know my motion sensor.
Wait, what is this?
This dude doesn't even know who Baby Gronk is.
That's kind of embarrassing.
Baby Gronk totally rigged up what he does.
Is that the Marvel rivals Groot guy?
yeah go by me by you just by you know hold on i'm making
noise so they can get confused watch behind i'm deployed
why can i talk to me it's fine we're
so concentrated oh enemies here watch out careful
they're probably gonna try and do the same thing as last
time yeah they're right here Watch out!
Gotta get a nasty hang.
Okay, they cleared the grenade.
Gassing the wall.
Nice.
Are you still walking through the left door though?
No, but I said...
Oh, there's people here too.
They can't get through.
One minute remaining.
One minute.
I hear someone behind.
Yeah, but I said they have to like walk through this
doorway.
Sure for I swear because everything's reinforced mm-hmm got
Definitely right here.
They have a sniper.
Why is one sniper?
Oh my god, the base are getting crossed.
Yeah, there's someone in the hallway.
Yeah, someone is in last one in this hallway Yeah, I don't
know where the last last guy is Yep Last guy's here baby
baby.
He's gonna want to finish Oh, he got me.
Yeah, I think we can wait.
We can wait.
Wait, just wait, just wait.
Just leave him.
Leave him.
I wanted to get kill leader, my bad.
I got hungry.
He's crouching.
10 seconds.
Yeah, he's crouching.
He's a crouching thing.
Nice!
Or I can just kill him, smokes.
Bro, that fucking risk.
That's the main character right there.
Holy shit.
Or I can just kill him smile.
I was really rainbow six sieging there.
I had one little spot on the freaking broken.
frame open just heating them i shot a tiny little hole and
then i like only look through it and then jinxie recorded it
and reacted to it and put it on youtube you were you were
straight aim chatting dude you're saying that motherfucker
is cheating dude it's insane this has got it this has got to
be gold this has got to be gold this guy's got to be alive
they're like oh my god you know it's a good clip when he he
turns into a tarot act go
the flow all right surely they try and attack somewhere else
this time because i think i see the vision with this i'm
just gonna i'm gonna save one of my motion for last push i
see it now i see it now let me get a lasagna getting the
four plate all right so if i put a door here
below this oh i can't now the phone like we still have four
reinforced walls left up
well i'm pretty sure i hear them near me i hear them yeah
the shots they're here okay cover me careful i'm like
listening that's getting me there's one there at the vent oh
wait right there nice big kill nice that vent is such a kill
hole Oh, oh, motion.
Enemy's here.
Watch out.
I was hitting them.
I was tagging them.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I got one.
I hear someone near me, I think.
My motion's gone, by the way.
There might be someone behind you, Gomez.
Badger, there's a guy like in that hallway.
I've just been taking shots at him to scare him.
I'll let you hold the angle then.
He's flash banging me.
I might need some help here.
I don't think he's watching.
I'm watching.
shit oh behind me behind me oh no yeah they pinched me in
that little office yeah heavenly's one hp right now i'm just
checking that's my armor oh that's your armor okay i see one
here they got 50 seconds they got 50 seconds i still have
smokes i'm just saying here he's crouched he's crouched you
gotta hit control wait why did i just do this here boom help
up heavenly one one nice bang that wall too last here watch
out for that I see four, Gomez.
I see four.
I'm okay.
Yep.
He's in that corner.
Let him come to us, bro.
I'm like, wait, no, you just want kill leader.
Fuck, I'm back for it.
Gomez baited me.
Just let's kill leader.
Okay, guys.
Okay.
He's about down.
Just wait.
It's also the dicey guy.
He loves the crouch.
Remember that.
Wait in the corner.
So dicey's dead.
Shot by his own teammate.
He's won.
You don't have to do it.
Let's put a plant.
It's they time.
Oh, they don't have it.
Yeah.
He's one.
He should kill him.
I think he's invincible.
Hold on.
Lord, head out.
That's the motherfucker.
I'm trying to play for our win.
Guys, if we win this, we get, we gotta win this, guys.
Last point.
This map is hard to attack.
No, it's not.
I don't think Wilson was working.
I don't know if Wilson was working for us, though.
Just make noise.
Don't keep sneaking in big flanky.
do this okay do a little bit of we don't got the pink-haired
cat girl do you want me to get bomb again or no you want me
to try the bomb okay honestly it seems easier to attack if
we're like going through be like yeah i think we actually
have to take the long way that's fine i'll just make more
noise from prep i'll just i was like doing this i don't know
i really like prep i mean like prep or back entrance or
pre-treatment room come make noise and meet in yeah we can
just i have the bomb so that you guys i'm just gonna wait
for you guys to make noise what if i just pocket sure for
every every swing but like i could just do that that'd just
be op as fuck right i don't even have to peek i don't know i
think it might just might be low op i can think we're going
that way always keep them guessing let me know when you're
in when you're in make sure they're confused i'm gonna scan
because if they don't know let me know what you guys are in
by the way because i can't reach in mark on scan are you in
are you ready hold on i'm gonna scan our making noise okay
three two one keep the corners nice that one's one inside
sticky oh are you kidding me that's the only spot i didn't
scan that's actually so unlucky that's life isn't it i can't
go in yet there's someone in this area i don't think i
should have entered regardless i'm gonna be real they shot
my motion by the way
Someone in this hallway directly Yeah, yeah, here The
flanker's watching me The flanker's watching me I'm wasting
his time There's a person on Gomez's body Yeah, there's
someone in there Oh, Badger, I can blow that wall open if
you're ready Okay, yeah, let's do that There's no Oh, so I'm
flanking you go Oh, they wall bank They're like a little
peak Ah, that's unlucky Oh, well Oh, this is bad Am I being
gaslit?
Oh my god, are you
Oh, he's your left this guy doesn't work what I can plat but
oh, it's just me go for it just go for the plant Plants in
the car.
It'll work.
Wait, what happened to you guys?
We got sure for sure for scan the room and the one spot that
I didn't get didn't like scan the person.
Oh, no.
all right well doesn't that mean you should look that way
instead of like wait but these guys but yeah we can do
defense now right and let them pick the map for some reason
everyone likes hospital for some reason this game hello
please choose a map or side for uh defense the the hub a
wait oh choose defense do you want defense or whatever you
want oh yeah we want the sound we don't we don't get to
choose the map no no we get to choose map or side so do you
want map or side oh dude i'd rather pick the map these guys
are just going to to pick hospital again then we'll do third
hub then all right third hub so is team jokey going for
third hub yeah third hub b or a we just did b didn't we
whatever map we did for the first round whatever that no
that was b yeah so you're saying we're doing the third hub a
now no we're doing third hub b no that's the map we did on
the first round so we should do that one shouldn't we since
we know that that's the map can we redo maps can we redo
maps yes you can Oh, then yeah, there's a B.
Alright.
Oh, my God.
Guys, I think Dicey's coming, catching up to kill leader.
He had 15 kills.
That don't mean nothing for nobody, bro.
We just gotta crouch, guys.
That's all we gotta do.
We just gotta keep crouching.
But every time I crouch, they shoot me.
so how does that work crow try dude i'm gonna get water
problem with crouching is if they do the aim down strat
you're only getting headshot which means you die fast not
really well yeah center mass yeah but like wait i'm trying
to be a smart fella not a fart smell here does the
sledgehammer work on reinforced walls yes yeah it just takes
two hammers oh yeah it's gonna op you don't have to use the
don't you are exposing defense oh they have to choose
they're gonna choose defense because it has a higher win
rate yeah these nerds are always picking the same map don't
we pick this map no we pick the map no but for some reason
all three teams all three teams that we played against they
all picked hospital apparently it's the best map i don't
know there's so many i don't know why it's just really easy
to defend maybe for them it's because it is the main problem
with that map is there's that one giant ass wall that has
literally zero entries towards it so you have an entire
inbuilt defense so it's like heavily defense sided yeah
that's why they want us on attack every time i mean it is
harder because you have to do something and they just have
to not do
They're asking you ready.
Everyone ready up.
Yeah, everybody readyed up.
Oh, my fault.
We're interrupting.
Are you guys ready for set three?
Okay, thank you.
All right, here we go.
He's so nice to call.
He's so nice to come in here and be like, you morons.
But press the pink button.
We got substitute teacher, guys.
The homeroom teacher was sick today.
I hate you guys in three different languages.
just please press the big button all right we're ready guys
are you ready i'm ready it's wilson time i'm ready to lose
and have doki sitting here by herself in the next three
hours please guys we can win more money just think about
that we can win more money heavenly's guys tongue out right
now Wilson's trap worked insanely well for this one.
All right, we'll run it back then.
Yeah, the Wilson's trap for this map is insane.
All right, who we go?
So we're doing this and then we just go.
That's pretty gas, all right.
That's a pretty easy entry.
You could actually do east entry hallway.
This is what we're going to do.
I'm going to smoke the right side like right here.
Oh, wait.
Right here.
And then I'm just going to go straight into the into the, oh
wait, no, that's window.
Oh shit.
Uh, is this a door or is this a window?
That's a door.
A window?
I don't know.
We walked in, remember?
We walked in from here.
I remember.
Okay, we just do the same thing then.
I got scan.
I can motion too.
I'll throw it.
Oh.
I got motion.
Wait, no one.
I almost told y'all with a grenade.
I pulled out the wrong thing.
Oh, that's going.
Checking corner.
I'll just bust it.
I'll just bust it out of the way.
Oh, I got one.
Busted, busted, busted.
There you go.
Two of his eyes.
He didn't get him.
Chucking every corner.
You're gassed.
Oh, you ran into me with the gas, man!
I'm trying to run away from you, bro!
You're running towards me!
What the fuck happened?
That's fucking tragic, dude.
That's shocking.
What happened?
So, Lord Headass got hit by the gas grenade direct, so it's
stuck to him.
I'm trying to run away from him as he's falling.
pulling me into a hallway where I get fucking railed.
That's so awkward.
Say come give me a hug before I die, dude.
Also, I just realized, if so, okay, I feel like I wanna play
Patch and Set for this.
Okay.
Because I can just wall the left side.
And they can't flink us.
I'm letting Jesus take the wheel.
All these NFs out here.
I'm like, yeah, dude, let's attack.
Yeah, dude.
My bad, my bad.
I was definitely playing for the vibes on that one.
But I was like, dude, if I'm gonna die, I'm not dying alone.
No, not the walk of shame.
You guys can check out, but I cannot have to stay here until
the end.
I'm staying as far away from now.
I'm likely it's better for me to leave as soon as possible,
technically.
We keep going.
Yeah, but you get 1K.
Yeah, but this guy got 15 kills last game.
Yeah, and we can stop him here and you can build.
up more kills motion detector plates oh they're like right
here okay oh he won't be won me he's very low but yeah
there's a guy in that hallway oh wait i bomb i can't okay
that was him but you're so low though that's fine i'm gonna
wall this though i'm gonna double i don't i'm not alive
Wait, how do we go away then?
Wait, can we...
Huh?
Shoot through this?
You can, but it's bulletproof.
You gotta go around.
I got...
Oh, he's in the corner.
He's in the corner.
Doki, I'm 1 HP.
I cannot peek that.
I know, I know.
Grenade!
Oh!
I'm up.
I'm not peeking that.
I'm 1 HP now too.
Oh!
There's people behind here!
He's downed.
Heavenly Wait, I can raise I can get rose the he fired me
Don't get I need I don't I can't I can't you're in Heavenly
you could really peek it you could peek it and kill him and
then try to get Gomez if you want but but yeah He's he's
hugging that they're crouching they're crouching you got a
control Please oh my god Or you can flank him.
Yeah, I can't do anything here.
I think Gomez is dead.
Yeah, I'm done Sorry boss.
That's okay i believe in you you just break it heavenly i
can plan on yeah i'm planning i'm planning right there oh
she's on side i didn't see you nice nice you don't have to
finish him you don't have to finish him oh i got hungry yeah
i didn't realize they were here i thought she was down the
other one my bad no no i i went to plan because they were
like you can plow i was like i can okay i'll stay alive for
longer than five seconds so we can hard breach it's okay so
i was trying to i was trying to do the the foam wall instead
but then i smoked twice which i didn't mean to do oh
actually i can use a breach hook why don't you just use that
well how does this work has anyone even used this before i
have no idea the breach does it work like as a single hard
breach maybe also wait hold on sure fork can you can you
scan right there with your thingy Yeah.
So then, so then we know if anyone's in that room.
Okay.
Cause I think it covers the whole area, right?
Uh, I don't, I don't think it goes the whole way, but we'll
find out.
It's fine.
It's a, it's a, it's a breach.
Yeah.
Like five, four points.
It's just so fast.
Why do I have the bomb?
I think we lose.
Oh no.
I mean, I can come over and grab it.
Okay.
Just do that.
Do that.
that motion i threw it here
wait didn't reinforce it i'm not with you for a motion but i
can come over now
i'm here oh no sh what all right it's okay oh there's
someone in the back there i just saw them like split second
i'm gonna go with heavenly this sucks i i can't peek it yeah
they're right here i can throw bottom went my plan works oh
there's a guy to your right there's a guy directly if it
wasn't for that guy it would have been a good plan because
you can't down though you just run in dokey you can't see i
don't know just stay there just stay there so you can revive
me oh wait they team killed what the i'm a stick prod team
killed two there's only one left it's a three bomb one i'm
rising so yeah just go plan b plan b the 3v1 it's a 3v1
someone go in first i have bomb i'm just gonna get down here
here give me the bomb drop the bomb i'll take it and i'll go
in because i'm good bait okay okay oh nice look at this big
ass stick i have look at this i'm a huge on stick to be fair
prod did none of you see what happened no prod killed two
yeah i'm sorry fraud killed two of his own teammates wait he
did yes that's why we
Let's go, a team kill.
Oh, by the way, the barbed wire is OP as fuck.
I didn't know when you're walking through it, your accuracy
is like non-existent.
Your bullets just spread around.
So that's how I killed Heavenly yesterday on accident.
That explains so much.
Also, someone break this.
We need this broken.
I'm reinforcing all of this.
That explains so much.
Why is that a mechanic?
Okay.
You want me to reinforce these two?
enemies here watch out any wire yeah what the fuck uh just
right here let's angle it boom foam deployed motion detector
i need a hard wall oh i hear them
oh i got a broken wall by me they broke a wall by me same
with me they're breaching it enemies here watch out He's in
the corner.
They breached it.
On me, on me, on me.
They're not in yet.
Here.
I'll delay them a little bit.
Back up, Doki.
Back up.
Oh, you broke my.
Broke my motion.
Oh, they know I'm here.
I mean, it's just gonna go off and tell you that they're
there.
It's pretty obvious.
There's something in that window.
On me.
I got one.
Nice.
There's two more.
Oh, last There's a guy here He saw me He went to that room
Yeah, yeah, yeah There's one more One more One more, one
more He's down He's down Here I can go Bye, bye, bye Oh,
what the fuck Oh my god I think he forgot to I think he
forgot to Reload his gun I was so scared Oh,
okay I'm all take good job team good job we'll take those
i'll put bye-bye damn i was kind of counting on doki to die
to like every one of those dudes so i can clean them up and
she just didn't that sucks what the hell users couldn't even
get my one guys it's because i'm so motivated right now i
mean this is the leadership that doki has instilled in me so
i'm just trying to do the strap man i do not want to be
alone bro i do not want to be alone i don't want to be alone
for to the broadcast oh by the way why why are we not
abusing this like little hole here that motion detector
place like when they try to lock it you can okay someone
break these someone break stuff break this nope okay you're
actually gonna reinforce over here
coming my way again like same as last time i got motion
where is your way oh this way okay i have to go along like
like uh north towards b i can't really i mean i can i'll
make a mindset make a little hole here
i hear someone punching stuff that's me that's me that's me
i was punching that yeah no i'm pretty sure i heard them
punching stuff oh that'll be awkward oh my way my way oh
they're trying to blow it open by the that was a grenade Can
I just do this?
I definitely hear someone in there.
I got motion.
For more charge deployed.
I'm just waiting till my youth hill blows up.
To do something.
I think we just play slow.
Oh, motion.
Oh, behind me.
Here.
Watch out.
They're coming.
Give me a game.
Yeah, I need help.
They're pushing.
Wait, they don't know about the tripwire.
They can just jump through that.
Mm-hmm.
Oh, on me, on me, on me, on me.
He's two.
That way, you'll miss.
All right.
Someone get caught in the mine.
Throw in the gadget.
I'm going, I'm running over to you guys.
They pinched here for it.
Oh, I get a team killed!
No!
That's the guy who like the crows measure.
Oh, never mind.
Oh, fuck.
All right, just wait for the plant.
They're planting B.
I know, but I don't know what I can do here.
You've probably got an angle.
Well, you can hold them.
They motioned me.
They know I'm here.
Good shot.
One.
It's a 1v1.
You got lots of bullets.
You have a hundred bullets.
You can slow people down, bro.
No, don't try.
Rush them down.
Tell you, bro.
No, they had a shotgun.
They have a camera.
yeah yeah yeah but you sprint at him he won't know what to
do he'll freak out he had a shotgun what the fuck guys you
gotta you gotta scare them bro these people get scared
easily these valentine players don't know how to deal with
anxiety it was it was just i think that one little barbed
wire i put in the middle of the map was not good or in the
middle of the point there was no point oh Well, I need to
help breaking this, huh?
Have fun by yourself, doggie.
Cover those up, cover those things.
Put it on the walls.
I'll put here.
Okay.
No more.
You're numbing that.
Setting wire.
Hmm.
I don't want to alarm anyone, but this is the last round.
Yeah, this is the last round.
This is the last round.
That there.
Okay, I hear them walking through over here.
I heard them breaking shit.
They're heading the barbed wire.
Oh, two on me.
Two on me.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, don't peek it.
Wait, I can spray this.
I can't spray this.
I'll just flame them.
over here over here over here yeah yeah yeah they're just
spraying the wall what the fuck they're just spraying that
wall guys they have the timer at 50 seconds that's when
they're gonna entry oh they're crosswalking like this
oh my god oh my god how do you see me i got one my god that
one oh your effect oh the reload i had the reload my gun oh
that he's like he's one hp though i i got him low with my
pistol oh good shot i fucked up oh you're one hp ggs guys
ggs good try ggs everyone ggs we tried three hours yeah
three hours of yourself now they just they cracked open her
stream bro that is over bro lonely mr lord gg's a block of
shame no heavenly and i dragged you guys down hardcore i
just got a lost all steam that match i didn't get a single
kill that's okay i just got outsmarted each time because
they kept shooting me through walls it happens there are
times we win our ones and sometimes we don't yeah sometimes
the winner i've gone one and six i think i went one and
seven one game oh i remember that that was yeah you didn't
know how to start yeah a walk of shame it is by the way sure
for don't worry you guys are free now i had i had 30 bullets
in my mag and i thought i had more i know the me is using my
tactical and it staying on the tactical but not oh i got i
got switching to your weapon with your uh with your antics
my bad that's okay you know usually usually it's the your
special weapon sometimes your gun you No, I can't really
make up with the gun just sucks.
Oh, okay.
But what about my gun?
He puts 20 bullets in a vector.
Where are the attachments?
What are the attachments in the game?
That's what I'm saying.
All right, but GG's.
That was fun.
Hey, GG's, everyone.
Guys, GG's.
Thanks for playing.
Okay, goodbye.
You guys are all free now.
I might pop in and out again, just to, you know, keep you
entertained every now.
three hours are you for real homeboy i literally have
nothing before you know i'll just like pop in be like yo is
this funny and then leave you dragged me to the walk of
shame heavily hey look the guy that can speak three
languages regardless of winning or losing losers
whatever I want okay goodbye thank you for inviting me
goodbye thanks for coming are you staying in the VC or no
yeah all right I'm just gonna if Heavenly is gonna be
hopping in and out of nowhere i'm gonna do it too okay ggs
i'm gonna go draw myself in league bye bye i would he do
that to himself all right guys well at least i wasn't at
least i got kills guys i was oh my god when they were like
run at him i i i it like pressured me i felt like i could
play slow there because i knew he had a shotgun and i didn't
want to run at him i was like i that actually like oh my god
that Fuck me up.
And I saw someone.
You fumbled.
I was like, what do you mean I fumbled?
They told me to run into a shotgun.
Like, what was I?
They told me to run straight into a shotgun bullet.
I know I had a shotgun, but he told me to run at him.
Yeah.
But I had less HP.
because I got shot though that's the thing he would window
shotgun fight no matter what because I had I already got hit
I already got hit didn't matter he just need to pump me with
a shotgun one time like he I need pump twice he needs to
pump once so that's why I wanted to play slow
yeah oh man yeah close up shot yeah so like it was he need
one pump I need a two pump That's why that like that like
got to me there because I thought I think I could have I
could have like clutched that there just that one fight I
definitely felt like I clutched it and I felt really I was
like oh my god but it didn't matter it was a four two anyway
yeah it was just in hindsight but the team was like the team
was fun it was fun the vibes were great I had a really
I had a great time.
I really appreciate everybody for coming and showing up
because they showed up here for free, technically.
You know, gave up their time to play for free.
And, oh my God, I got knocked out of my own tournament.
The walk of shame.
I was like, oh, can I end stream?
After I get knocked out, they're like, no, you gotta stay to
the very end because it is your turn.
And I was like, that is true.
But not last.
It's like, I was like, yeah, it's you like, it's your turn,
but you should stay.
I was like, that, that is true.
I should stay.
Like, the stream of shame.
um yeah fandom from the next term any any team that knocks
me out they're not allowed to play in my next tournament
that those privileges for yeah i was like no don't make me
still continue to go live after i lost no
Um, I'm not gonna watch Twitch.
I'll just watch the Observer.
I'll just join in the Observer channel.
Where is it?
Uh, it's best of three.
So, like, it should be pretty fast, right?
It's best of three.
I think, like, the match- It's so fast.
It's so fast that, like, messes with me.
Yeah, I'll just join the Observer.
I feel like that's the easiest.
I have access to the channel to join the Observer.
yeah it's a super fast game i think on mobile this game will
do really really well in general i'm pretty sure this game
is like if they release a mobile version this game is like
built for mobile too because especially because it's top
down now i'm like i'm literally slouched up right now
because i'm like don't need to play i'm like slouched onto
my chair Don't need to play now.
I don't need to focus up.
I can chill now.
Yeah, this is me sitting up here.
And this is me slouching.
But yeah, I appreciate everyone for...
Uh...
I don't know that...
Everybody gave up their own time for free.
uh to participate uh in this tournament too for my team uh
and i really appreciate it yeah i really appreciate everyone
uh for joy i really appreciate russian badger heavenly cheer
for and super gomez uh for coming in and joining us today
because like i said like um you know they gave up their own
times uh to do this and you know they weren't paid to come
here but they still showed up um and like hanged out with us
so i really appreciate it was really fun chaotic crew that
is just that one round that one more pissed me off that's so
hard that one round pissed me off so hard because i knew i
could clutch this i could clutch it but then it like i like
got like jumbled up for that um but like other than that if
all the rounds were really really fun and good yeah it was
still it was like really funny overall we were like i'm
pretty like our team was the most I'm pretty sure our team
was like the least serious yeah the our team was the least
serious we had no plan our plan was just to go in go in and
hope for something to happen the fact that like we we
managed to get this far I'm pretty sure the other two teams
were like hard calming and super serious with plans and
everything and then my team was just like well let's get our
ones like yeah get
your ones doesn't get their ones yeah I mean I feel like we
ours was like really fun to watch though I'm joining the
lobby i'm just gonna watch i don't know how to observe but i
don't know how to use the observer but i'm gonna watch get
me in here that's right
bro the fact that i like how like you know the enemy team
team killed their own team and we're like, we're like, oh my
god, we're so, like, I don't know who it was.
I think it was Gomez and, uh, it was Gomez and some, I
forgot, I think it was Gomez and it was Gomez or Badger or
Gomez and Heavenly.
They're like, oh my god, yeah, look, we're winning.
And then I'm like, and then me and, uh, SureFour was like,
you do know they just team killed their entire team.
I mean, we're so good.
They were just like, bro, they, they're like, we're like,
bro, they, they lost too.
They lost two going in.
What do you mean?
Bada no, bada, bada, bada.
Bada, bada.
Bada, bada, bada, bada.
Get ready, guys.
Just get ready.
What?
Who's talking?
Yassine.
I know you're nervous, Yassine.
What?
Who's talking?
Do you guys hear that?
Yo, Connor, try not to bait in this game, alright?
Try not to bait in this game, brother.
And Simon, try not to be last alive.
Challenge, Mission Impossible.
Are they, like, talking?
Oh, they're talking to their team.
Are they not using their VC?
Why are they using the in-game voice comms?
Yeah.
They're listening to their in- No, it's here.
They're listening to their In-game VC Right now.
I was so confused.
Bum.
Bum, bum, bum.
I don't know.
He lost Kill Leader?
Yeah.
I mean, he was gonna lose Kill Leader eventually.
We don't make it to the finals
what the fuck brother good luck why is he oh is he open mic
oh my god he is he's open mic right now he's open mic at the
moment oh no mvp unfortunately the casters wanted to do um
and left click to shoot this time right all right the caster
wanted to do only to the winning team, which makes sense.
You know, it makes sense because they won, so they have to
have an MVP in the tournament, you know?
It makes sense.
Oh, can the other team hear him?
I guess they can.
Yeah.
So the vote would just be, like, whoever is on the winning
team, which I assume is Muda's team because they've just
been steamrolling everyone.
But I don't know anyone on this team.
think needs the money the most i think that's the i think
that's the easiest because it's 2k
just don't vote for the captains vote for the players that
volunteered their time and just don't vote for the sponsored
captains just vote for anyone but the sponsored captains
because the rest of the players gave up their times to be uh
um to be uh to be in this tournament all right how do i do
this i want to swap oh okay all right let's see whoa wait
how do i like i don't even get to i want to spectate how do
i spectate oh the red team isn't there yet i assume
these guys actually look like they know what they're like
pinging like where to go and everything
all right most likely this team would be winning so i'm just
gonna see what they're doing what are they doing that makes
more sense
what are they doing oh
wait i think because oh they warmed up though to be fair
these guys us they're more warmed up now oh they're using
your util what the fuck oh the shared vision they're more
organized for sure they're playing together as a team i
think oh yeah they they're they're actually playing together
uh compared to our team whenever we defend we all split up
You know
Which makes sense They should just wait that these guys are
crazy.
They can literally all they What the fuck that's that's
illegal Yeah, look at them playing it together You can play
together as a team is that legal
Dang, the game looks so much easier when they No When they
play together
It's a completely different game
It really is Teamwork, gross I think also we had a lot of
like lurkers too of people just lurking around like
we were always like super like they were just like uh what i
noticed is that we had a lot of people who would like not we
would just like split off and then they would just like pick
us off one by one teamwork what the fuck is that
what the fuck is teamwork just get your ones you can't get
your ones and you're not Then you're bad at this game.
You're not a gamer.
Oh, he's low.
Oh my god.
That was such a good peek.
Yeah, they would, like, re-rotate out.
That's so smart.
They're actually using their brain.
Like, he got his one, and then he rotated out of here.
See that?
And then, let's all, like, congest in the area that we know
they're at.
Like, holy shit, what?
That gun is insane.
Yeah, now they're all converging on him.
What the fuck?
You can tell they come from...
Yeah, you can tell.
These are two Valorant, full-on Valorant teams.
They invited two Valorant pros, and then they invited all
their Valorant friends.
I'm pretty sure Mooder's team is, like, all Valorant pros,
right?
um pros or uh or like trying to be valent pros
yeah they know their angles
because i saw like some of them um some of them had were
like i saw like some of them used to be valent pros and then
we swapped to content creation i know we had no strats
was like motion like there's people there guys motion god
damn nerds
well they're actually using util i don't think we've ever
really used smokes they don't even get barbed wires do you
guys notice that what the fuck do they get you just use
nades i think that's it yeah i don't oh wait know they do.
I don't... I didn't see any of their bribe.
Oh, there it is.
What the fuck is... Oh, it's over here.
Okay.
I don't know.
Say, what is that?
Oh.
Oh, that's crazy.
That's a crazy peak.
Oh, there's a lurker right here.
Oh, my God.
He didn't see him.
Oh, there they got the first point.
Yay.
Okay, now they're on attack.
You guys use motion wasp thank you that was me i'm the
motion girl i i'm i'm the motion girl that's me
yeah notice they all stick together in one area and then
slowly like they just slowly uh move around and stuff i
noticed that too
You got like two and a half more hours, right?
Wait, no, it's happening.
Okay, to be fair, they're progressing actually surprisingly
very fast.
If you're, I don't know if you're watching this, but I could
tell why they're winning their games compared to us.
Okay, I can tell you right now, Doki, I am not watching the
games.
No, it's crazy.
They're like actually playing together.
That's such a unique concept to me.
I'm like watching, like, you can actually play together as a
team instead of having five flankers.
Hey, first of all, Doki, why would I be watching your stream
when I'm checking out the link in the description that
brings me to cherrypick.gg slash Doki bird.
That's true.
That seems way more interesting.
Knock on the light.
I'm going to click it again.
Instead of watching my stream, you can play the game
yourself, right?
In PUBG blind spot.
Like, chat, why are you looking at her DPI and her...
I don't know how to pronounce that mouse pad.
gg slash dokey bird holy shit look they're all just together
that's that's such a unique concept to me wait the stream is
on steam that's so cool oh wait really actually yeah if you
click your link the stream is live on the main broadcast or
my stream like am i on there what the fuck they're all just
like holding hands Oh, it's just watch the community play.
Am I watching random Korean people?
Everything is in Korean.
So it's not me.
Maybe it's not.
Yeah, I don't think.
I don't think I might be Asian, but like I unfortunately
don't speak Korean.
You got to be like Jay, who speaks Korean, English and
Chinese.
Oh my god, they're so confused.
What is...
What?
Is prod killing everybody?
What is happening?
Yeah, prod locked in.
He locked in finally.
Is it?
Are you for real?
Is he going to clutch up?
Yeah, he is.
Oh my god.
He like, this is embarrassing.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh my god.
He's using a shield to block it.
He has to go.
He's got five seconds.
You better run, buddy.
Bro, did you not?
Oh, he's hitting his shield.
He's hitting his shield.
That is so smart.
I even don't even do that.
Wow.
wow i know why we got knocked out i know we our brains are
not big enough for that oh it actually is really good though
he's a very very good player yeah i mean he did he he did
shit on us during the last round i think you like downloaded
the game today too i did oh you're cutting in and out oh no
oh you're back you're back you're back okay well i came back
i i just feel like picking the attacking side was a really
good idea it's a very good idea like we gotta pick the map
no we know the map's well enough we gotta pick the map big
dog that's what we're that's what we're picking and who's
who's was that heavenly or gomez i i don't remember whose
idea it was i like how our teammates were either the
scariest people alive or on the round it's just depending on
how we feel that particular round you know is this the same
heavenly that was here yesterday just fracking out of his
mind that was that was kill leader on day one like what
happened yeah if your chat wants to have a laugh let's see
how far down the kill leader board heavenly fell i think i
actually moved up too unsurprising now that you not reload
your weapon.
Yeah, I didn't reload at all.
I actually got kills for it because I didn't reload my gun
and actually went in.
Yeah, this is so stupid.
Why would I have lag on Discord when I'm basically in the
technological center of the universe in Seattle, Washington?
This is stupid.
Wait, Dicey killed three and then the team killed.
Alright, Dicey is very good.
I think he's one of the guys was killing us a lot yesterday
yeah he was there's just some guy said it's just like god
you just kill so many people and you don't die i gotta i
gotta cut me a slice of that just killing people and then
not dying i'm gonna get on that train yeah oh does that mean
you're coming back if they do another one are you coming
back if i ask you to join absolutely oh shit let's go
we should have a real challenge though next next stream of
this we can only speak korean let's see how all of our
korean gets it's okay we just need to know like the basics
you know kill there and res me that's all maybe if doki
organized some more scrims and map analysis you might want
to show up i'd show up i'd show up then accidentally dc by
unplugging my ethernet cable you know they actually want us
to have a rehearsal and I should have said like there people
are not showing up.
I don't think we should have a rehearsal I I feel like 50%
will not show up Doki Doki can move on to some greener
pastures.
It's just like all right so now you got heavenly Gomez and
Mr. Beast.
Wow Mr. Beast has shown up to play in PUBG blind spot.
I don't think they can afford Mr. Beast I wonder even how
much he gets paid to do any sponsor.
It was like millions, right?
I just picture his bank account as just like a bottomless
bucket that he can keep pouring out of or like stick his arm
into and there's no bottom.
What are they doing?
They're doing our strat.
This doesn't work.
Not against prod.
I mean, I mean, Subroses, Muda's team is winning.
Only, oh, that was not smart.
Okay, Muda could absolutely destroy.
Oh, no, he didn't do it.
No, no, he didn't.
He didn't do it.
He didn't see the flank.
He did not.
He did not see it.
Yeah.
Yeah, bro.
Let's reenact the civil war.
Let's just walk in a straight line there, straight line and
die.
Wait, wait, wait.
Muna got one.
He got two.
The flank is where.
Why don't our flanks do that?
I don't know.
Every time we play.
Because I was the flanker and I would.
You would what?
Didn't know where my control key was.
I was going to see.
You know how it is.
like strafing left or right and like you can't hit the
additional key with your other pinky that you need to
because you just your your hand doesn't work like that yeah
yeah you don't you hate it when that happens holy shit
chat's not even taken into account one of our team members
was basically disabled heavenly and the other guy had a
broken wrist by disabled i mean that he was scrolling tick
tock and that is a handicap because he is not paying rodded
yes damn all right muda's team got the first point if they
win the second game it's over i actually get to zaka early
it has to have to be three hours doki has got her time card
in the slot i have this card out right now she's hovering
her she's hovering her palm over the smack button i'm at the
machine right now which is really lame because pubg blind
spots are really fun it is a fun game but also like it's
sort of a bit shameful to be the to be knocked out in my own
tournament but then people be like oh and of course she made
it to the final she rigged it for herself but what do you
play doke you play like the the what do they call like moba
hero shooters like rivals you play those i play i play yeah
i just play i play shooters in general the only is just
tactical shooter because i'm just i i'm just i i get
impatient i guess because i've been the most patient i've
ever been in a shooter game like i literally sat here if you
play shooters doki hop on armor right now hop on armor three
i'll give you the mod list oh my you are it'll take you six
years to download it there's only 127 mods and uh oh my god
that is so old at one point No, no, no, just so you know,
every game you love is Arma.
Every game you love is Arma.
That's true.
Every game was built off of Arma.
Because let's think about it.
Let's just go back from PUBG Blindspot, all right?
Who created PUBG Blindspot?
The guy that created PUBG, his name is Brendan Green, aka
Player Unknown.
He learned how to build maps and games in, you guessed it,
Arma 2 and Arma 3.
And the original VR that he made was just a mod of Arma 2
and Arma 3.
armor it's all armor rather give a shout out to to the
pioneers the pioneers of the shooter genre but too bad like
we we did improve it though with pubg blind spot and you can
play it try it out right now by clicking the link pinned in
the chat and the description below guys you already picked
uh gg slash gokey but you got to capitalize the d that's the
only capitalized or you can just click it instead of typing
it he just clicked the link yeah but that doesn't feel right
I feel like you want to type every in are you also somebody
that AI generates images instead of using watercolors on a
pastel or something on like a canvas no no no no that's a
meme that ain't me I mean it's just convenient it's just you
know accessibility you know having the link right there that
you can just click on it no you don't get it dokey I can
generate a whole 3D animation just with this one click, with
this one prompt.
You know, people are now generating Minecraft builds now
instead of building it themselves.
It's gross.
Just make the decisions yourself.
That's where the fun is.
Just build the dirt house.
I know you can't build it, but just build the dirt house.
At least that's something.
Nah, just for you, I'm going to manually type out this link.
They're going to see.
Give me that plus one.
It's in manual.
Yeah, remember the https colon slash slash uh cherry pick
okay we're gonna see if lowercase dokeybird works all right
try it oh i'm in oh i typed in dokeybred whoops dokeybrib
there you go it works yeah fascinating i love technology
that's pretty cool look at that he worked so hard guys hard
typing that imagine if he had a fractured wrist and had to
type that that's actually crazy our kill leader had a
fractured wrist and did better than all of us combined is
that what's so sad is I thought he fractured his wrist like
playing rivals or something no he was on vacation like no he
was like a compound fracture too like you snapped your shit
up playing no it's crazy apparently he told me he was like
he could have died or something if he didn't like land his
fall because he was literally like on the cliff or some shit
in like while he was hiking and he literally like tripped
and fought and then like he could have rolled down the cliff
if he didn't like land on his wrist to stop himself going
outside i know i was like that's his first mistake i was
like why would you why would you go outside you could you
know how you could have lived by never going outside oh man
i don't have any friends can generate them now for like a
couple tokens depending on your lm of choice exactly who's
your best friend i don't hang out with claude the majority
of the day actually most people don't even know what claude
yeah i was gonna say who's claude you don't know what claude
okay claude is basically the best ai round who is he though
well i assume he's french because his name is claude but
basically there's a lot of tedious stuff that I have yeah
like let's say I got to do the same repetitive thing 200
times to like process motion capture data or like edit
notepad files for materials and games yeah he'll just be
like I'll write you a script for that so you don't have to
click 200 times and break your risk you know I'm saying oh
holy shit I just saw seven nays being thrown at this one guy
why do they like all of these people are always on top of
each other I don't get it it's working I know that grenades
to kill one person.
Oh my god.
Oh, they're doing this trap.
Wait, why do we play on this map?
Wait, this map, we're so good.
Wait, do they let you plant anywhere inside?
Yeah.
Like, just the room?
That is cool.
Holy shit, they just gunned them down altogether.
Wait, this is a sick-ass map with the easiest plant.
Oh, they want to know unless...
yo i agree with a bomb a bombable no man smh no romers dude
where are your romers come on dog no romers in 2026 this is
embarrassing everyone's just together okay my time's up
chat's being like i want to hear dokey's voice not this
dumbass badger so i'm gonna go wait no don't go wait no the
stream is it over yet no i have to go over again Wait, no.
Okay, bye, Doki.
Alright, thanks for coming.
Bye-bye.
That was fun.
Wait, no.
Oh, man, don't go.
Come back.
Who said that bad to him?
How dare he leave us?
Just like my dad.
That was fun.
That was nice of him to pop out.
It keeps me company.
It feels less shameful.
Seeing them do the things that we didn't do.
Like, seeing how they're not playing.
They're playing like their life depends on it.
That's right, guys.
Badger's just buying milk.
Guys.
Just like what my dad told me.
Are they like outs?
No, they're inside I think it'd be cool.
You can just swap plants When will badger come back doki you
said he'll come back 20 years ago look that the milk place
ran out of milk.
So he's just waiting for a custom order of milk
Holy shit I think this team is better on attack for sure
Like what the fuck is going on right now?
now i mean it's literally oh my god what the fuck yeah that
angle was sick congrats on attorney dokey the vibes are
immaculate with badging boys thank you super chat fudge
thank you thank you yeah that's fine i'm glad i'm happy that
they're dropping by to keep me company.
Alright, please, Muda, please win this game, Muda.
Muda, come on.
Yeah.
They're, like, actually playing, like, insane strats right
now, like, Subrosa's team.
Come on, Muda.
If you win this, it's over.
I mean, it's crazy to see what you can actually do.
What you can do in this game.
When you have actual strategy.
We're going for a third match.
Damn, you see that?
That team actually got kills.
Unlike ours.
And who are...
Heavenly.
Bye, Heavenly.
Damn.
So that's sad.
I got kills.
I got kills
Oh Oh Holy shit Okay that was such a good scan though What
the fuck This guy took a Molotov in his face And that's the
only HP He lost like that's Bullshit I saw that Molotov
Explode on this man's face Okay
And he actually, like, that's the amount.
Oh, he lost in the end.
He's just okay.
Guys, he's over here.
Oh, wait, he has to, like, super flank.
God, they're so...
They play so slow and cautious.
They actually check their angles.
I don't know what's that like.
I don't do that.
You don't need to check angles.
in the games I play.
They're so smart.
They're actually so smart.
Holy fuck.
Oh my god, they won that.
Bro, what is he?
What is he?
Oh, is it?
Did he plant?
Does he not know where the bomb is?
Oh.
I was just like, where is he going?
Does he not know where the bomb is?
The crypto has been diffused.
Yeah, no, I tunnel vision hard.
The shotgun has two shots.
That's why I, like, you got to hit your shots.
The shotgun.
And it has the slowest reload time of the century.
I think he was confused.
He's like, where is it?
That's like the worst part.
In the moment I stopped reloading, I actually locked in.
From day one to day two.
I actually, day two has actually been my best performance
for the game.
The moment I stopped reloading, I knew how to play the game.
Yeah, like Badger was like, who lived that?
What the fuck?
Dicey, bro, he was like, I can take them down myself.
Yeah, and then Badger was like, Oh, I thought you were going
to die.
I was like, what?
I was like, you were leaving me to die?
What do you mean you were leaving me to die?
That shit does nothing.
The impact needs?
Yeah, Dicey wanted to get his five.
Bro, that is crazy.
He lived that Muda doing the longest plank of his life Oh my
god, we actually might get a third match Oh, was that a
flashbang?
I thought that was an impact grenade
Yeah, I thought that was like, I thought that was a It
looked like an impact grenade So I thought that was that
they use their utils so well they're so bad with util that's
like one of my worst skills I just don't know how like I'm
rude I mean I did use my my movement movement thing really
well I didn't know how to use my grenades real well I feel
like I was always like fuck up my nades
my prayers are coming true
I think like my I think my movement placement was really
good like the placements were like the movement uh sensors
yeah my motion
yeah nade's not it i was motioning though we got some motion
wait they're actually doing our strap we had this strat
you're stealing our strats to be fair they're using the
strap better than us
I think I was also like the only one pinging people
Because I re-binded my ping The ping keys like default is
like pretty awkward It's like X for like pinging people And
I just pinged it on my middle mouse I like re-bind it to my
middle mouse
It's just awkward It's a Z or X That's why I like re-binded
it
Oh shit.
Yep.
Wait, actually, this is Muda's team.
So they win three more points.
Oh, everybody is so low.
I mean, this... Oh, this is a horrible... Like...
It's so hard.
I feel like some of the maps have like the weirdest bomb
plant areas, you know?
They're like super far from the entry... Entries?
The entrances?
Or like, they're super close.
Oh, it's a 2v1.
2v1.
Oh, 1v1.
Oh!
Dicey!
I think Dicey's gonna get kill leader.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
2v1 that.
That was clutch.
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum.
Bum, bum, bum, bum.
I think it's easier to just kill everybody versus planting
the bomb or like or like plant the bomb and then use it as
bait I think use as bomb bait all right I actually now okay
I feel like if you're gonna get all right give MVP on this
team it would be dicey that guy's literally like carrying a
team in on his entire fucking back um I don't know about
like Muda's team I feel like most out of everybody if he if
this team wins if Tokyo rigging the MVP I mean it's on my
channel this me making analysis guys I'm not rigging the
votes if it's like an obvious observation we all know I
think you actually might win MVP and a kill leader at this
point
Okay, the thing is, Subrosa's team might most likely get
Kill Leader only because they played more matches.
So they have an advantage of playing more games compared to,
like, Muda's team.
Because Muda's team didn't...
Oh, wait, they're open-miking right now.
They're open-miking, but...
Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey.
Hey, yo, study that Google Doc.
Study that Google Doc.
You guys get very talking about...
wow what the fuck hey yeah they get to they get one set to
grab kill leader so i think sub roses seems to get killed
either because like they had more opportunity to more
opportunity to um to like play games to go to go there get
there and then i don't know but i don't know who's going get
mvp on moodus team because i feel like all of them were
pretty equal i don't i didn't see it like i don't see like a
like they all seem like they're really at the same level
regarding like gameplay i think dicey is literally carrying
their entire team on his back i'm gonna pee while they're
oh yeah i'm gonna pee okay guys i'll be right back go swap
team prod prod swap teams go defense oh it's the plus sign
top right on top of the map
i'm back i'm back didn't miss out didn't miss out
wait what did i say at i said something at
the the style is like that comm is very appreciated dokey at
5 30 but i don't remember what i said was it what
did i say guys 18 minutes ago what did i say
it was when what did badger and i say 18
18 minutes ago What did Badger and I say?
We said a lot of things
Panic Alright At least guys At least it's not hospital Wait
is this hospital?
This isn't hospital right?
I didn't even see what the map is Oh my god we're at Thank
god we're out of the fucking hospital I'm so tired of the
hospital hospital on that.
Every team plays on a hospital.
Are they breaching that?
Oh my God.
They're so smart with their utility.
We don't have none of those utility.
Oh my God.
They're pooping up.
Oh.
One down.
Two down.
I don't know if the shield thing is a working strategy.
It has to really...
worked I will say also he's like 1 HP I feel like the shield
strat has not actually worked in anyone's favor I mean I
know that he's there I like how he's just like oh shit what
do I do oh wow that was a nice peak though
yes he's reloading he took two shots and he has to reload
there we go
He has one more shot.
There you go.
Let's see it.
That's not reliable.
It's not reliable.
It's like, you gotta hit it.
Because then after that one shot, you fucked.
Alright, it's 1-0 Muda.
But Big Shield, though.
I don't know.
I guess like the big...
I mean, the Big Shield team got one.
But I don't think that strategy has been really...
working or maybe because uh they're more coordinated than us
for me i didn't think the big shield was working very well
it worked the first time only because they didn't know what
to do and then after they figured it out i was like guys i
think we gotta stop with the big shield
they like figured it out guys what the fuck why did he damn
that's cheeky as hell that's so cocky
Look to the left.
They're going to come to the left.
Dude, why would you look to the...
He just kept looking to the right.
Sub-Rosa, why would you not look left?
There's more than two angles.
Oh my god, that gun is strong.
That gun is so strong and most people down so fast
Oh, that's it He missed the bridge He missed the Viking
bridge That's embarrassing for you He actually missed it
That's crazy No way there's no no way he wins these there's
no way he's like so fucking low right the thing is i'm
pretty sure he can shoot from oh he can't we're see the
other plant is like so there's no way he has a shotgun
unless he whips that oh it says one more oh red oh he
reloaded it's fucked yeah see he reloaded it's fucked
I think if he like If he rushed him while he was reloading
Or nah I think he could have He was actually reloading
But he had the other team Warp just killed him after Yeah I
lost So it's spectating time
That's alright I had fun though Even though we got third
place I had a good time.
I did, though.
I really did.
My team was really fun to play with.
I really appreciate it.
They were all really fun to play with.
Yeah, I'm in the commentator chair.
They know he's there.
I mean, what are they going to do?
Breach it?
They're like, where do we go?
He actually is all like, where do we go?
Oh, he's gonna be a lurker.
That's funny.
He actually was actually like, wait, where do we go?
Because both doors got...
Oh, shit.
Yeah, Dicey got one.
Yeah, Dicey always getting the entry frag.
Holy shit.
Oh, he got knocked, but...
Oh, shit.
Oh!
He couldn't crawl!
Oh, no!
He's trying to crawl here!
What the fuck from 80 miles away?
Nah, he's dead.
There's no way they're getting that res.
I swear to God, how do they have so much utility?
All I get is one grenade.
I feel like they get like 20 nades or something.
like 20 fucking nades.
Doesn't it?
Oh, there it is.
It's 5.
10 seconds remaining.
Oh, they're crazy, friend.
Oh my god, they actually got it.
Wait, 10 seconds remaining?
Bro, they win.
Oh my god.
Oh, you got a double kill with the shield.
That spread was crazy.
Okay, maybe Simone deserves the MVP from that team.
wait no wait that's with dicey never mind dicey deserves it
more
one pump two kills now it's between simone and dicey i'd
pick dicey the shoddy collab yeah i think sub roses he might
actually i think he's gonna sub roses team was warmed up
from us that's always how it goes like literally a muda's
team way like two hours I think yeah two and a half hours I
think for us
oh breach what the fuck what hit him okay that hit him I
mean that was that was a idea that that was an idea that
they had no what the fuck was he thinking like what the fuck
what was that idea like now they have to get the bomb how
are you gonna get the bomb now like how are you gonna get
the bomb oh breaching
yeah they still have to get the bomb they just got play bob
like literally they just got play bob oh i mean that's all
right i feel like it's so hard to figure out who's mvp on
this team because they're also like equal oh wait dynamic
has six kills for this team oh they actually got it oh that
guy's crazy the hell mary the hell mary plat Never mind.
Dynamic now.
Dynamic is carrying Sarosa's team now.
Yeah, the thing they fucked up on is that they split up.
When they play together, they actually do a lot more.
When they play together.
They weren't playing together this time.
And then they're playing together more.
Alright, someone make note of like, what...
Oh, so one make help me make know who the who do you guys
think is MVP MVP our mooters team What do you who do you
guys think What do you guys think is MVP our mooters team
Yeah, who would have thought playing as a team is a good
strategy in a team game Who would have thought it's a crazy
idea
Honestly, very...
Oh my god.
Oh, he's...
Oh, he's just trying to bait for this.
He's revolutionary.
A revolutionary idea.
Yeah, they're baiting for this.
They're forcing them to use all their U-tail.
Like, why would you waste your U-tail here?
Why not just bait for A?
Like, just go to A.
Right?
Like, breach here, and then...
What the fuck?
oh wait yeah wait how the fuck do you breach this oh my god
wait how do you get to a
bro a is so hard to breach they're like maybe they're at a
what the why is prod here did he just log back in where the
fuck was prod where was he in this entire game see him
running back
oh that's that's crazy I was gonna see where did they come
from oh my god the cross is actually real holy shit dicey
clutching that up to make it a 2v2 oh my god dicey I knew it
guys I told you dicey literally made this a 2v2.
It was a 5v2 and he made it a 2v2.
Oh, if they win this, it's over.
Guys, if they win this, it's over.
He cleaned up.
He really did.
I told you guys, he was like baiting here.
He was baiting at the bottom.
And they ignored him because everybody was making sound on
the side.
Amura's team loses this is over.
Yeah, Dicey has to be MVP for that.
That was so clutch there.
Maybe Das?
I guess so.
I mean, he has the most kills right now.
Yeah, I'd say Das would be MVP on that team.
Why are you doing the same thing again?
They're baiting.
Breach!
Oh, no gas.
I feel like that's such a waste of utility.
oh and then they're lurking to yeah but then they oh that
was a good zone name wait was that their own team that's
through no it's dice yet that's dicey's utile holy shit what
the fuck oh they're making noise so they can go this way but
then like now they all know they're rotating though weren't
they yeah Wouldn't they all know now?
What the fuck happened?
Wait, what happened to them?
Wait, what the fuck?
They lost their entire HP.
What happened?
I actually don't know what happened there.
Was there a nade there?
I did not see the nade.
Jesus Christ, they're actually all one.
Did they like nade themselves?
Like, what...
I like...
I don't fuck...
They need...
They needed themselves!
Oh my god.
I literally was like, what?
I'm pretty sure the enemy team did not throw in that.
I was like 100% sure the enemy team did not throw that name.
I need to know if they needed themselves or not.
I'm gonna go...
I don't know if there's replay.
I'm gonna check if there's replay.
I have to.
That's a good nade.
Yeah.
Now it's hype.
Now it's intense.
Yeah, after that clutch up, they naded themselves.
That's so true.
They worked so hard to clutch that fight up and then they
naded themselves.
That's true.
Throw for content.
Get it to three to three.
Make it three to three.
All right, what's the plan?
Wait, what the fuck?
Where's the rest of the...
There they are.
I was like, where's the rest of the team go?
Oh, they know.
They hear it.
Yeah, but then they know they're coming.
Wait, can they...
Wait, they can literally peek from here, though.
The split is intense.
Damn, they're so good at throwing nades and stuff.
It's like they do this for a living or some shit.
It's almost like they do this for a living.
Where the fuck was that from?
Oh, Subrosa got one.
4v5 now.
I don't know if splitting up was the plan, guys.
I don't think splitting up is ever the plan.
Oh, they're doing this shield strat again.
I don't know.
I feel like splitting up is never the right idea.
one minute remaining oh yeah they split up and they lost one
they're not doing very good at lurking maybe if they're
lucky someone will need themselves again oh so roses he won
I see with the entry oh unless no no it's 3 oh wait 3v3 it's
3v3 right now yeah but he's like 30 seconds
Oh They gotta plant 20 seconds Oh my god the platter is so
far I'm dead Oh Oh they lost Oh my god Subrosa team won Oh
So Rosa's team won.
GG.
I think it was a little awkward because their planter guy
was so far away.
I think that was a little awkward.
I think Dicey deserved the MVP there.
100%.
Look, we lost to the...
We lost the team that won.
So technically we're second place if you think about it.
We almost won, dude.
We all, okay, but there was a little closer.
Their game was a little closer.
Just a little closer, you know, only a little bit closer.
But it's basically second place for us.
Is there even replay?
I won there.
Math checks up.
Mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
Yeah, I think it's best of three, right?
Most likely, yeah.
It is best of three.
But we did it!
Oh, my God.
to sub roses team um that was a fun tournament to watch even
though i did send the commentator share guys no you guys i
signed a commentator share but it was it was ggs it was a
ggs there i wonder if i can watch replay i really want to
see that i don't know if i have replay do i have replay no
no I don't think I have I can't see that I don't think I was
like locked into the POV whatever the fuck happened there
like it was like whatever it was it was interesting oh I
have a solo interview let's interview the loser the team
that got knocked out first how did you feel I'd be like It's
cool sitting in the chair It was My team was like peace And
then it was just me
Oh man The shade The interview of shame
I need to ask I need to know like Was whose team self-nated
themselves Was it subrosa's team that needed themselves Or
Muda's team I actually could not I forgot which team it was
yeah congrats I wore it our team helped you guys warm up
like even though even though we got knocked out first today
our team had the most fun it was the roses okay then I can
ask that I'd be like so was that did you guys nated
yourself?
Like, what happened?
It had to be a self-nate.
I did not see a nate from the enemy team.
I was, like, watching the enemy team, and I was like, wait,
there's, like, three people with no HP left.
Like, what the fuck happened?
I swear to God, they had health.
Like...
Bum, bum, bum, bum.
Honestly, I would say vote for Dicey.
That's where I'm influencing the votes right now.
I say vote for Dicey.
I see because that guy literally made a 5v2 a 2v2 and won
the game
yeah although we were third place we were first place buys I
agree
I agree guys
most votes are manipulating the votes oh yeah take that oh
yeah if you're complaining take that to the host of the
tournament That's right.
I'm the host of the tournament I am the manager You
complaining then complain to the manager Which also happens
to be me
If I could I would have given my own team the money I'm
joking I would not I would not I would not
Yeah, we warmed them up for them.
Don't use that power.
Be the change you want to be.
That's me.
It was rigged from the...
They stopped me.
They stopped me from rigging it.
They were like winners.
Only winners can have MVP.
Bro Whoa, hey Heavenly Did you have fun bro?
Yeah, I had actually had so much fun Dude, so roses team
nated themselves And then they were literally like So
healthy and then I think they nated themselves And then
three of them were like literally 1 HP But they still won
though We technically lost to the champion team Yeah, but we
also technically beat the champion team one time too So
technically we're second place if you think about it We're
second place Yeah yeah we get paid out bro yeah yeah so like
who how do you get mvp oh it's just it's the winning team
mvp we i manipulated the votes i was like yeah i should all
vote for dicey because that guy literally it was like 5v2
and then he made it a 2v2 and then won the game wait wait
he's the one that blew him up no we don't know i don't know
who blew who dated themselves but like he was the guy that
we had the problem with the most when we played against that
oh bringing in the superstar we've already stolen her
channel for far too long dokey we apologize we'll give it
back to you we promise we want to thank you obviously for
the creative match and yes i've got to say first let's get
out of the way first right you said you had to do the walk
of shame yeah i had fun at the chair the commentator chair
yeah why did you come in here you should have come in here
and covered it in here with us no i have no input i was just
like being like wow so this is what a team play is like like
i was like oh my god everyone's playing together what what a
revolutionary idea i was like our team was like all right
guys let's get our ones and then it was like two of us
anchoring and then all everyone else would just be like
lurking around and it was a good show in there i'm not gonna
take anything away from you you had team play you picked the
site especially semi-final you went for the breach i'm not
buying that you didn't have team play you guys were just
having a lot of fun yeah we were definitely a fun team we we
are we i don't even know we had plans going in we just like
alright guys let's go in and then we had we just adapt on
the fly and i'm like we did take a lot of points though we
got a lot of kills from that from from our our no no plan
strat oh look i've got to ask a question before we move on
but i'm gonna ask questions about your team who's your mvp
you can pick yourself i don't mind how's your mvp in your
team your team come on but we won't get our MVP won't even
get paid though pay but he's the love that's counting i want
to know who was who was the person who's going to get the
love oh man that's hard i didn't think about that i thought
we were all mvps that's why yeah i thought we were i i will
you know i will say uh maybe maybe super gomez because he
was playing with a fractured wrist but somehow he was yeah
he's playing with a fractured wrist and he somehow was kill
leader it was like on day one it was also kill leader for us
on day two So, like, I was telling, like, magic.
I was like, it's crazy that Super Gomez had a fracture wrist
and then had more kills than all of us combined.
I was like, oh, my days.
If I would have known that, that's why you put Super in
front of his name.
He's one hand, just killing people all the time.
Yeah, he was like, guys, he was like, guys, it's good that
we got knocked out because I should not be playing this game
of this wrist right now.
But you know, I will say, even though we got knocked out
first, a champion team so technically we're second place
because we warmed them up
yeah we gave them that warm up and more importantly i took
your game strategy as well because they stacked together
they put a wheel yeah they're like what the they're like
what the fuck were they doing like let's make sure we don't
do that like look you warmed them up you sent them on to a
victory but it's big ggs how let's let's just break down
before we bring the the grand final interview though how did
you find it how did you find pubg blind spot the game the
dynamic the agents what's just kind of takeaways or or maybe
the convince of the people that might be watching that
haven't downloaded the game yet why should they be getting
this game downloaded and playing all right if you have a
group of friends it's actually really really fun because we
were so silly you know we were like we were so silly and
chaotic on our side and also if you get the game and try it
out by the way click on the link pinned in our chat by the
way Wild PUBG blind spot right now.
Anyway, so what we definitely learned is that we should all
be crouching when we're shooting because we're like, wait,
wait, crouching is so OP.
And that's how we always died.
We died because people were crouching.
Yeah, you're not alone that one, Mark.
I mean, Mark, tell us your story.
Tell us your story about your first game, huh?
Yeah, I forgot that the control button shoots the gun down.
So I was that person just shooting it by everyone's head and
not getting anyone.
I'm like, why is no one dying?
yeah i re-binded that i was like could left control his
crouch for me so far away from it yeah absolutely love it
though enough really good play obviously it's been a
pleasure having you win obviously unfortunately quite get
through to the finals but we do need to bring in the
interview for the finals because subrosa yes you warmed them
up and obviously we set them on their way to a victory but
they were a team that always kind of went down game number
one but were able to kind of work themselves into a victory.
So is there any kind of takeaways before we bring him in
that actually, like, do you know what?
You did warm him up, but how strong were there as a team to
actually fight against him?
They were really good at adapting on the fly, and they
played together a lot, which was something we, like, didn't
do.
So like, whatever, they, like, bone rushed us.
We were like, oh my God, they're all here.
So they were very coordinated.
I could tell they were very coordinated, and they definitely
had like comms and stuff and everything so um oh they're
here they're about to say right there's a little trick here
we're meant to like g them up first okay we're meant to go
well look we've got to say thank you for you but more
importantly we have the winners not just one but we have the
whole team in chat big ggs though subros are the
heavyweights though of dokey bird's creator well done ggs
let's um there's a lot of you here let's let's Let's start.
Dicey, let's start with you, mate, because you got the
kills.
You've already got money in your back pocket.
Big GG's, man.
How did you find the game?
Because you were a killing machine.
It was a great game.
It was a steep learning curve about the movement and holding
angles.
But I feel like since we all came from Valorant, all five of
us, it really translated over with the strategy and just
having an open mind.
And just the natural, I just feel like we're all just
naturally gifted in the FPS or just shooting game genre.
So it was an overall fun experience.
but good definitely definitely a team game we get the vibes
from the from the team let's let's let's get some more
thoughts though dynamic you came into after day number one
kind of one of the mvps one of the guys leading the charge
though what was the kind of game strategy for you guys
though getting ready for day number two uh honestly we
didn't prepare as much as the other team unfortunately no
massive page document no like 10 page you know no yeah it
was bad they did a lot of preparation which is respectable
but it came a little short but we had a good igl a subrosa
leading the charge with all these strats it was honestly
just all up to his calls and we uh just had to execute them
well so ggs look big ggs there obviously prod look you come
in second day um you're playing my favorite character the
agent of choice though drop out you played it well um
obviously you did bounce about a couple of others what kind
of set your thought process did you did you guys have what
you guys were playing, attacking or defensive, or was it a
bit of a free room?
Yeah, I want to be honest, everything was a free room.
I honestly came into this tournament today on the first day,
thinking we were guaranteed going to lose, considering I was
seeing the other levels.
But as soon as I saw the names beside the levels, I knew for
a fact we were bound to win this tournament.
Moody's team was very, very bad for the amount of time they
put into this video game.
And considering we heard their comms and they said that they
had a lot of documents studying our gameplay, I was very
confused on why they looked like they were running around
like happy that we won absolutely love it simon come on
let's hear from you is it the same thing were you guys just
having a bit of fun a bit of a banter in the game we're not
going to talk about any specific rounds but i'll tell you
there was one around specifically where prod first like for
the first time used a grenade i want to kill two of you we
saw it we saw it and oh yes and he didn't pick drop out the
next time if i remember right as well he kind of swaps it up
we we said it's going to be a lot of you after the game for
sure we told him it's going to be bad well look it was uh
it's an interesting learning curve it's a learning curve to
victory look don't you look i've got to give you the stage
this is your show look the the the lad to yours ask away get
the strats out of them oh yeah no i the only thing i want to
ask was like did you actually need yourself because i like
looked there it's like how did three people lose hp so fast
i was like I was looking at the enemy team.
I was like, they did not do anything.
I was...
Connor, if you don't mind, can I answer this one?
I mean, he honestly, he did nade us, but he really felt bad
for the other team because it was actually embarrassing what
they were doing.
So he kind of was thinking like, let me make...
He was trying to think like, let me make it fair.
Let me make it fair.
Let's do a 3v5.
Because honestly, like, you guys saw on the mainstream, when
it was 5v5, like...
they were sorry like hey hey every time they peeked around
the corner i feel like i had 10 seconds to kill these guys
oh my god it was definitely a pity nade i agree with them it
was it was 100 of pity nade we thought we put a bit of a
challenge on our backs and you know it's uh it didn't help
them that much did it so yeah the end is the same we
basically just delayed the inevitable
you know i want to make it close you know like a 3v3 gate
like 3v3 yeah yeah exactly i completely agree oh yeah we're
definitely not going to talk about that one round where
we're me and dicey had the 2v5 the entire thing oh yeah that
one was good i was crucial we were just flabbergasted though
we were like what's happening there's one there's two
there's three they're all gone like what the hell happened
it felt like they lined up for you though they just came one
at a time You're just like, yeah, free, free kill, free
kill.
There's just some things you can't prep for in the Google
Doc.
That's just, that's all I have to say.
There's just some things that you just can't prep for.
Yeah.
Absolutely love it.
Either have it or you don't.
You know, like, yes, it is.
Well, look, last one for me before I let you guys go and
I've got to, I've got to ask you, Subrosa.
Yep.
I've referred to you guys as the heavyweights when it comes
down to this tournament.
It felt like you as a team always took the first big blow.
lost to start with and it started to feel like this was the
game plan like a full sense of security you take the loss
you adapt you change was that what you guys wanted to get
into was it was it mind games at the at the very first
offset or was it kind of a let's see what you guys have got
and then we adapt to how you play so honestly since we have
less hours than everybody we kind of have to download their
playstyle you know and and has our team or us five like we
have very high load every I will say that is not true our
team had even less hours but I'm not I'm gonna let him have
this I was like excuse me our team at two players with level
one yourself a champion round of applause though you're back
in the line share the prize I'm not gonna have lost words
from you guys I don't think they have the least hours I mean
literally the Google document the chosen one
well i like to say uh this game was actually very very fun i
didn't know to think about it at the beginning but it was
very fun i will say though if you guys do a tournament in
the future i'd hope for some stronger opponents because the
end game hopefully we actually get some competitive players
for the next i just want to say that's that's mainly
directed at team muda the chosen one yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay i was gonna say my team helped you guys warm up there
my team
most fun to play with because they actually made sense what
they did oh no we did we did not have a plan going in i just
want you to know it looked like you guys did it looked like
you looked from here like they did don't thank you we're not
buying you had game strategy i'm telling you if you heard
our cops there was no no thinking in that head there our
plan was get our ones that's our plan like
store a plan guys look thank you very much you've got the
prize pool you got the old winnings off your pop and we'll
get you some more competitors next time to try and step up
to the plate the chosen ones are going to be you so thank
you very much guys we'll see you on the next tournament
piece thank you thank you so much guys cheers guys congrats
thank you okay you don't go anywhere you're staying here
with us though you gotta stay it's your show because
unfortunately we do have to hand back the channel.
MVP, though, has gone down towards Dicey.
So obviously Gigi's there.
I manipulated the votes there for that.
Yeah.
I hate that.
That's part of your job, right?
I was like, everyone vote for Dicey and they were like, all
right.
So he's got some extra money as well on the board.
So he's got the kill and he's got the MVP.
So an extra $3,000 plus the $7,000 for the team, though.
Look, Doki, final words from yourself look as again
apologies we've stolen your channel we need to give it back
to you but come on final thoughts for you before we close up
i want to say thank you again to pubg blindspot for
sponsoring us today for today's tournament if you guys want
you guys saw this tournament i was looked really really fun
you could check it out and click on the link ping in the
chat or like in the well for youtube you're on youtube in
the description below uh but yeah the game has been really
fun it was fun seeing like the different strategies
everyone's doing and you know the
was happening everywhere um and it was definitely enjoyable
experience with my team and also the other teams too it has
been good fun fadix final clothes for you well check out i
think doki has pinned a link cherry peak dodgy slash talk
about you should definitely check that out and thank you so
much for having us obviously doka but it's been an amazing
tournament uh we had a lot of fun we learned a lot of stuff
as well even though we obviously obviously put in the hours
as well so there's lots and lots and lots of stuff to still
unlock to still experience until um you know kind game it's
just dropped it's it's a week old essentially they worked on
this for two years so make sure to check it out and honestly
fine thought it's been a lot of fun thank you so much for
having us doki button thank you so much for having me as
well mark thank you for being here and casting the
tournament for us we love this we've we've done a few we've
done a few of the guys um from early access beta through now
towards what we have get yourself as you said in doki bird
has got the link in the descriptions below or up and around
on the screen it has the biggest takeaway though is going to
be how funny it's gone fadix yeah no i just want to say
thank you to your community as well don't give up because
they have kept this company in the chat and that's just been
they've all been super and engaged not only engaged but
they've also like strategized and they've topped us with an
analyzing they've they've they've seen way more stuff than i
have to be honest while watching these games so uh shout out
to your chat genuinely like an amazing community definitely
amazing community and more importantly the community that
out there again we have to do say thank you to pubg and pubg
blind spot for setting us up dokybird though thank you very
much for allowing us borrowing the channel should we say for
the period of time though for the last two days for you
though at home in chat it has been amazing you have been
fully engaging and it has been fun from us to cast it i want
to say a big thank you to all the production staff all the
admin and everything that goes from behind the scenes from
the observing to making my mic come up live for you guys
that's it from us though more importantly make sure you
smash and download that game because it is fun fun fun with
yourself or with a group of mates though i want to see you
in the discord and more importantly on the next doggy bird
dog creator showdown that's it from our start we'll see all
you guys next time peace bye bye everyone
are we still live thank you very much for letting us make
your channel mate all right we're still live on my youtube
channel though i just didn't know we were can we do the
swear words now margot is there are we finished oh we're not
i've been my team and i've been swearing entire time on the
youtube i think You're safe.
YouTube, you're safe.
Don't worry.
Yeah, we gotta get on that YouTube mark.
100%.
That's been good fun.
I really enjoyed it.
This has been the highest level so far, Doki.
So we've done ones with pro Rainbow Six and pro PUBG
players, and we've done a mix with PUBG and Rainbow Six
players.
It felt like the creator one.
You guys learn so quickly and you adapt so quickly.
It has been a lot of fun to cast.
Oh, I'm glad.
I'm glad to hear that.
Yeah, I'm glad you guys had a great experience in the
tournament.
Yeah, my team they're like they're like good luck sitting in
a chair and they're like peace out I'm sure They're like
good luck and bye Tokyo like now don't leave me
No, no, I was not doing the professional comment.
I want to leave you guys with a professional commentary My
commentary was like what is he doing?
Is he stupid or something?
That's my commentary and be like look at this guy throwing
20 names what the fuck's he doing right and thank you again
guys tgs yeah bye-bye thank you so much take care that was
fun guys you shout again to pubg blind spot for the sponsor
for uh for today for the last two days stream and for uh and
for creating this tournament uh you know it has my name the
the pubg Lion Spot team did a lot of work organizing all of
this.
I gave advice what needed and everything.
Huge shout out to the production team for all their hard
work and everything.
And he shouted to casters for casting everything.
Huge shout out for all the teams that showed up to
participate in this tournament.
They gave up their own free time to do this, to learn this
game.
And to play a insane couple of games.
And then to my team as well.
playing with Heavenly, Gomez, and SureFour again.
I felt like our team bonded very, like, mixed very well
chemistry-wise, and it was really, really fun being with
everybody.
But yeah, guys, thank you, everyone.
Tomorrow, most likely, I might take tomorrow off and we'll
do Lunar New Year on Wednesday instead, because I think I
need a rest day.
I think I really need a rest, guys.
Like, it's been non-stop.
gas so i will most likely take tomorrow off on coming back
on wednesday wednesday for lunar new year stream uh but
thank you everyone for the huge support and thank you all
for watching the pubg blind spot dokey bear creator
tournament or creator match i hope you guys enjoyed watching
all the teams and if you want to support this stream the
tournament and uh um and um and everyone who participated
please feel free to click on the link pinned in my chat or
in my description Check out PUBG Blindspot yourself as well.
Hey, guys.
I'm going to head off now.
I'm going to peace out.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture checked.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you step for me, head to bed, because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.